This is Jocko podcast number 68 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good evening.
Echo did evening.
So we've been doing some Facebook lives lately.
Facebook live and they've been pretty cool interacting,
getting a lot of questions.
But here's the deal on the Facebook live,
I think the first one I did,
I got 3000 comments or questions in one hour and it's something like 40 or 50
questions a minute,
which is one a second,
which means you can't answer all of them.
And I started looking at some of the questions I,
there were some really good questions on there and there's also a lot of common
questions that pop up that maybe I don't address or haven't addressed.
And I said,
you know what,
if a lot of people are asking the same question,
there must be a need to know or people are interested in what the answer is.
So I kind of threw together some of those questions from Facebook live
primarily.
There's a couple other ones that I got from Twitter and or Facebook message.
Is that what it's called?
Facebook message messenger?
Yeah.
Like when somebody direct messages
and you know,
with that,
if there's people that are sending me messages and s and stuff through social
media and,
and even through email,
I can't answer all of them right now.
I just can't and I apologize and I appreciate what you're sending me,
but I can't always get to them all.
There's a lot of them coming in.
It's,
it's not a disease.
I don't have enough time to answer them all.
I look at them and you know,
I'll try and throw back and answer real quick sometimes.
But um,
a lot of times I just don't have time to answer them off sometimes.
Yeah,
I read them all.
I do read them all.
But you know,
when I'm looking at a limited amount of time and I have a ton of Facebook
questions coming in,
um,
it can be hard.
A,
if you do want an answer,
let me give you a thumbs.
It's something that is helpful.
If you want an answer,
ask like a really simple question.
Yes or no,
or should I do this or that?
You know,
should I go to college or join the military based on the situation I'm in right
now that I don't have any money and I'd have to borrow money to go to college?
What do you think I should do?
So there's a couple options there for me to answer.
You know what I mean?
It's going to be pretty straight forward on that one.
I'm going to say join the military.
You want to join the military anyways,
go get after it,
boom,
done.
So,
but if you give these long questions that then you're looking for an open ended
kind of answer.
It's hard for me to get around to them.
Now.
Those are also questions that I normally might pull into the podcast because
they do require more of a response.
So if that's what you're looking for,
yes,
that's a good way to send it on Facebook or on Twitter.
Hey,
if you need to,
if it's an open ended answer that I'm going to have to think about are on and a
half to discuss with you,
that's cool.
But if you just need an answer about something,
just answer,
answer,
ask a direct question,
I'll get around to it.
But during the Facebook live,
there was a ton of questions and it was really cool.
I'd never done Facebook live before and got a lot of good questions.
So with that,
let's go to this,
uh,
some Q and a from the Facebook
and Twitter.
I'm a man and Twitter.
These primarily came from Facebook live.
Oh Dang.
Look,
I,
I went through every comment,
Dan.
Yeah.
So it took some time.
But especially to see my computer started lagging,
which,
and I know I talk about being mad at computers or printers and copy machines,
but when my computer is lagging,
that also can get me angry.
Yeah.
The computer's pushing it,
pushing.
It's luck.
I just want the thing to work quickly.
Yeah.
That's the whole thing though.
That's the whole thing with computers.
It's like,
of course you wanted to work more quickly that like if you get a cheap computer
tents,
I don't have a cheap main thing.
Oh yeah.
So you have,
you have expectations.
Yeah.
It makes sense.
I want the thing to work quickly.
Yeah.
I almost got a t one line and you know that is Internet wise.
I thought that that was like old school.
No,
it's the t one line is,
is when you're,
you're getting it in and they guarantee 99.9% you know,
up and going and never break.
Never have any issues.
I almost got a t one line,
one line I think I didn't do it.
Wow.
Hey,
that's up to you obviously.
And with that I think,
uh,
let's go to the question,
the first couple of questions.
Okay.
[inaudible] first question,
do you work out every day?
Okay.
Yeah,
this is a question that a bunch of people were asking me and I thought it was
pretty evident that I do work out every day,
which I do.
And then I also thought that there was a little misleading
statement in the success magazine article.
And again,
I don't know what I said on some of these questions are how I answered it at the
time or what I explained or how well I explained it.
But there was a misleading statement that that on this particular day I had
already lifted in the morning at zero four 30 and now I was lifting again at
nine or whatever time it was and then I was going to lift to get,
it was like made it seem like I was lifting just over and over again throughout
the day,
which generally I don't do.
Generally when I wake up in the morning I lift and by Lyft I mean workout by
workout.
That might mean lift.
It might mean do calisthenics.
It might mean sometimes it just means stretching.
Right.
But rarely do I stretch.
But like yesterday I was feeling a little under the weather for two days,
wasn't full on sick.
My,
some of my family members got sick,
they were really sick and when it hit me,
it didn't hit me as hard because I,
you know,
fought against that against the illness.
So I was a little bit sick.
But one day I was the one,
I was like,
okay,
I'm just going to go in and stretch the next day.
I was like,
leg day,
you know I was going to go do squats and I did squats,
but if anybody was to come and witness that workout,
I would have to be ashamed of myself because all I did was basically go in there
and go through the motion,
put a little weight on the bar move.
But yes I do.
I work out everyday,
so even when I'm sick,
I'm going to work out right.
I'm going to work out and when to do something because I think it's healthy to
do something.
Now,
another question that people say,
he's like,
do you lift and do Jujitsu in the same day?
Yes,
absolutely.
All the time.
Almost daily.
I'll another branch question to that one is do you lift before Jujitsu or after
Jujitsu?
I like to lift before Jujitsu.
I want to go into Jujitsu a little bit tired.
As a matter of fact,
some of the young guns at the gym,
they'll,
they'll say,
oh,
you know,
I'll go into role with them at night,
and the young guns will say,
Oh,
I already worked out.
We were still hard to work out today.
I'm not all fresh,
you know,
I say,
well you think I'm fresh when you think I've been doing all day.
So,
so,
so yeah,
I like to work out before I do Jujitsu and I like to surf.
If there's good waves or even marginal waves,
get a little surf session done.
And if I can get,
I don't like to use the word cardial,
but I'll use it.
It's nice to go for a little run,
a little jog.
So that's sort of like my grand slam of day.
Oh the three,
no,
four four,
yeah.
If I work out,
you know,
Lyft car,
uh,
calisthenics or whatever,
then do some kind of a gain.
I'll use the word cardio,
go for a run,
go for a jog,
go for a swim surf.
That's awesome.
And then you throw the Jujitsu on top of it.
That's a grand slam for me.
I love those days.
And those are the days you go to sleep at night,
you know,
those are the days you,
you,
you go to bed and you feel tired.
You know,
that's one of the things in,
in the book that's coming out the field manual discipline equals freedom field
manual.
I talk about sleep and one of the things I talk about is,
you know what people are saying,
how,
how do you fall asleep at night?
Cause a lot of people,
you know,
we all,
everyone has trouble getting up in the morning.
But then when you start saying,
okay well I'm going to go to bed earlier,
people have trouble falling asleep too.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people and even me.
So what do you do to fall asleep earlier I got a couple of steps in the IT field
manual.
One of the steps in the field manual is be more tired.
How do you be more tired?
You work out harder during the day.
You Drain yourself physically and mentally during the day.
That way when you go go to bed at night,
you will fall asleep.
Yeah.
And I got the whole thing laid out in there,
but that's one of them.
One other note.
So that's it.
You know,
do I work out every day?
Yes.
Do something every day.
Do something,
do something.
Even if you,
even if all you have this 10 minutes,
do a hundred burpees,
you know,
just do a hundred burpees just at a minimum.
Make that happen.
But also sick.
If you're sick,
do what you can.
Get a little sweat going if you're injured,
If you're sick.
Caveat,
that doesn't mean go train Jujitsu cause if you're sick you make everybody else
sick at Jujitsu and I didn't,
that's not cool.
So if you're that kind of sick,
don't do it.
But other than that,
yes,
I work out every day.
I try and train every day.
I would stay active.
Yeah.
Bottom line,
it's going to be hard though to try to mask your routine onto someone else.
You know,
like you,
you can't just go into,
let's say I'm a guy,
I work out one at once a day and it's like just,
let's say it's a strenuous workout,
not super strenuous,
not like hard.
I can't just be like,
Hey Jocko works out four times a day on his good dance.
The limit.
He start doing that.
Like you can not only get hurt but it won't work via,
and that's another misconception is that every single day that I go that I work
out,
I'm going level 29 does self-destruction.
Yeah,
you can't do that.
You can't do that.
It doesn't,
you can't do it.
You just can't do it.
I mean,
it's not like you can't do it because it'll hurt you.
You just can't do it.
Right.
You know,
you do squats heavy one day or you go through three or four days of going really
hard.
The fifth,
sixth day,
one of those days you're going to be like,
okay,
I need to back off today.
Whatever did it date is so I'll,
I'll do some kind of workout.
I'll still go,
I'll still get it on,
but I'm not going to go level 29 you know,
self destruction.
And when I was going to bootcamp,
there was a,
they would say there was a room attached to the main hall,
the main barracks where everyone was this open bay barracks.
And if you've got in trouble for something,
they'd send you to the side room and they'd say go in there and self destruct,
which meant you did what you did and they had a list of exercises and it was,
you know,
jumping jacks,
pushups,
you know,
sit up.
Just a bunch of random calisthenics.
What when they'd send you in the [inaudible] I think it was posted and then you
went in there and you did one of every exercise then to have every exercises,
then three and then four,
then five and then six.
And one of my buddies who ended up being a CEO who's a great dude who I went to
bootcamp with,
he's like,
he's he,
he is the only guy I went to Navy boot camp with and we both ended up in the
seal teams but the,
the chief that was running it was like,
you know,
whatever is seamen apprentice,
this kid in there and self destruct.
And this guy was a,
was a wrestler,
a college wrestler,
legit college wrestler.
Great Dude.
And he went in there and you know,
normally people are done by whatever that you know,
five or six repetitions or maybe eight repetitions.
He was in there for like an hour.
He came out just dripping with sweat.
It was,
I knew,
I knew he was in there.
Uh,
getting out for sure.
Yeah.
The wrestler version,
the rest of the different,
it's different than some,
you know,
guy from wherever.
That's you know,
a non wrestling,
a non wrestler.
Yes.
I still have to put quite simply,
yes.
Thanks.
See they'd just kind of leave it to you.
You've got self discharged all and that's right.
He was the,
that's what it was.
He was the master at arms in my bootcamp,
which I don't even remember who the wrestler Guy,
the rest of the ride he was,
he was the master at arms [inaudible].
We when we were both from New England to,
and so we had had driven the flown down there to Florida,
all on the same plane.
And of course we were both kind of,
you know,
what are you going to the navy for?
Oh,
I want to be a seal.
What are you going for?
I want to be a seal too.
So we kind of had a little bit of,
okay well at least this guy's kind of getting after it in some way.
And honestly he was a college wrestler.
I was probably like a little punk to him because he's thinking what does this,
I was just a high school kid,
go non Razon rest of there going uh,
I want to be a navy seal and yeah.
So anyways,
he was a master at arms,
that's what we was like mastered arms,
kidded that room.
It's self destruct.
So that was a good time.
So no,
I do not self destruct on a daily basis,
but I do get it on every day and definitely pushed myself on a regular basis.
Yeah.
And that's obviously going to depend on what you like,
what is the results because you're not at a point where you're like,
hey,
I need to really get in shape.
I need to lose 25 pounds or something.
I'm not saying that,
you know,
it is interesting though is the days where I'm getting the,
the Grand Slam going,
when I get to Jujitsu,
I feel good.
The I train way better when I'm in the zone,
when I've been working out,
when I've had a good workout,
I've surfed,
I show up.
Did you just do I feel great.
I don't feel I'll feel tired but I feel better.
Right?
Yeah.
It's kind of like your second round of rolling.
If for whatever reason I don't get a workout in the morning or I only get a
really short workout in the morning and then I go train Jujitsu,
I f I never feel optimal.
And as a matter of fact,
I have a personal superstitions slash curse in my own head that if I don't work
out in the morning,
I am going to get injured.
So,
so that forces me to work out even when I don't want to.
Cause I said,
well I'm going to train tonight.
I don't want to get injured because there's been,
I think two injuries that I've gotten from Jujitsu.
Both of
them happened when I didn't work out in the morning.
One of them,
yeah,
I didn't work out in the morning and I showed up and went to train and one of
them hurt my ankle really bad,
like a high ankle sprain and that was bad.
But I didn't work out in the morning.
It must a minute.
And I think the,
yeah,
well apparently think the other one was,
I think the other one was a knee injury.
No,
it wasn't unusual for her.
I think it was a shoulder injury.
Anyways,
whatever it was.
It's also that day didn't work out in the morning for some pathetic reason,
you know,
it didn't work out.
So for me work out,
it's mental prep,
it's physical prep gets you ready for the evening,
the zoo's yets.
I think that's,
I think that's called the availability bias.
When you kind of,
you draw that conclusion,
you know,
in your specific case,
oh,
it stands out in your mind on this emotional level.
So it's like,
you know,
you really happened though.
So nevermind cognitive.
I'm not telling you what I understand what happened,
but you have to consider all the times in your whole digits a career that you
didn't work.
That's what I'm saying.
Then I was the only tool.
It's it's,
it's a such a small number.
It's such a small number.
I bet you it is.
I bet you there's 10 times in the past 10 years that I didn't work out in the
morning and I teach and I trained Jujitsu that night.
Yeah,
210 that's bad on,
yeah,
you can't,
you can't consider it.
You can include that and that's probably pretty generous.
It might be like five because sometimes I'm on the road and then I didn't work
out,
but I didn't train Jujitsu,
but for me to be here in my hometown with access to my garage gym and the
Jujitsu,
for me to just say,
Oh,
I'm just not going to work out today.
I don't say that.
Right.
It's not very common.
No.
Yeah.
I would say if it was a muscle strain or tear or something like this,
I would say that would maybe make it a little different because you're stiffer,
you know?
Yeah.
But then again,
ankle too.
If you're super like warm,
you can stretch your ankles and shoulders a lot.
So I don't know,
maybe you might be right.
I could have it completely.
Certainly sounds like I'm right,
but statistically I think I,
when statistically,
statistically,
let's say it's inconclusive.
Okay,
so 20% is not conclusive to,
okay.
No,
it's not.
You know what I'll do,
I'll keep working out.
Given the quantity,
like you'd have to do it over time and then if there's like a discernible 20%
then you could start to conclude,
okay,
I'm 20% more likely.
Okay,
well that's fair.
That's,
we can make that a statement right now.
Oh yeah.
I'm more statistically is 20% more likely get hurt if you don't,
which is pretty big out.
Yes.
Yeah.
Those aren't good odds at all.
I know I'm working out every day now.
That's what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
I used to do that like,
but I would go hard workout then go Jujitsu.
But same thing though,
I think it's mental.
Unless you're doing it like seven days a week for you know,
a few weeks,
then you can start to feel like,
hey,
or your nutrition is bad or I don't know,
something it to go,
you feel better,
you feel better sometimes.
Sometimes.
Not all the time though.
I know sometimes I'll feel better if I don't work out,
but,
so I wouldn't say that necessarily in my case.
But I think it is more mental,
you know,
in Jujitsu,
like I think it's natural to put pressure on yourself to perform in Jujitsu
training.
You know?
Cause I think it's part of it.
Like when I go in,
I'm going to rule against you.
I'm going to try to do good against you.
I'm not going to every single time I'm not going to go in and be like,
let's just see what I learned today.
Let me work on my weaknesses and try to learn and you're going to turn to when
I'm trying to win.
And there's that element.
I think most of the time for most people,
so mentally will play these games or we'll kind of psych yourself out like shit,
not at my best because I'm kind of tired from working out so I won't be able to
perform.
Now the pressure's on.
Maybe I'm going to roll with the guy who was my level,
me and my instructor is going to see me roll with him.
I'm not going to do as good as they normally do.
He will think I'm not as good as I really am.
You know?
It's like you're saying there's mental pressure when you're at the edge.
That's why I think that's why people will say,
oh I worked out today.
Oh I don't want you to judge my performance necessarily.
A Primo excuse in a way.
Yes.
That excuse.
Yeah,
no you can't because it would be a lie too.
Yeah.
Cause I would actually go and say,
Hey,
I didn't work out today,
therefore my game is going to be weak.
That's what I would have to say.
But that's not the case for you of the time.
Yeah,
and it's pretty rare I think.
I mean,
in my experience it's pretty rare that I'll work out even a hard workout in the
morning and then go roll at night and then it affects me like,
yeah,
I feel too,
it's pretty rare.
No,
now I will get so sore sometimes,
you know,
if you do squats or you a hardcore,
like a hardcore kettlebell workout,
I'll be sore and it takes a few minutes to get that soreness out of the body.
Once you're on the mats and sometimes somebody will be doing some movement
that's grinding on the quads and it hurts you and makes you Zeki a little bit.
Sure.
So I was jumping,
I was parachuting,
I had like hardly,
this is like when I was,
when I was in the seal teams.
Okay.
That like this morning was parachuting and I didn't have that many jumps.
Right.
I wasn't an experienced freefall.
Parachuters parachutist at this time.
And the guy we were going jumping with was an extremely experienced,
highly experienced,
thousands and thousands of parachute jumps.
And he took a crew of us and we were all pretty much new jumpers.
We didn't know what the hell we were doing.
And so,
so we go up and there's a ceiling,
meaning that the clouds are low and so we can't get to full out,
tattooed and so he goes,
hey guys,
we can't get up to altitude.
We're in the aircraft.
This is almost,
you know,
this is one those cheesy like a movie
type scene where we're in the aircraft and he's Kinda yelling like what's going
on to us new guys and this guy was a master chief [inaudible].
He's like,
hey guys,
we can't get up to altitude.
We're going to just do a hop and pop at three grand or something like that.
Meaning we're just going to go at a very low altitude,
just going to jump out and pop our parachutes.
And I'm sitting there.
I've never even done a hop and pop before.
I barely knew how to get stable coming out of an aircraft the way you go
through.
We used to go through free fall school.
It was like a rapid,
rapid evolution where if you did correct on one jump,
they moved to the next one and I did my jumps correctly so I didn't have a lot
of jumps.
So then we get this guy saying,
and I only jumped at 13,000 feet before this.
So you have all kinds of time.
If you,
if you mess up on your exit,
which if you don't know when you jump out of an aircraft,
when you're inexperienced,
you can get spun around.
As a matter of fact,
Andy Stumpf talked about how he started spinning out of control and it happens.
Well,
when you're at 13,000 feet,
you start spinning.
It's okay.
You've,
you find your body position,
you get stable.
We called it flat,
dumb and happy,
meaning you're falling flat and everything is stable and good and then you can
pull your parachute and it's fine.
Well,
at 3000 feet you don't have time to do any of that.
So when you come out,
you basically have to come out and immediately adapt to the airstream of the
aircraft and you have to get yourself stable and then you need to pull it really
quickly.
And so I'm kind of thinking to myself,
I'm trying to think of myself,
I have no idea how to do this.
And I've,
I know him that I've messed up a bunch of exits and I knew that I'd gotten
unstable a bunch of times jumping out and you know,
it just find my time and get stable and to be cool.
So anyways,
this mastery,
it's like,
hey guys,
we can't get to altitude.
We're just going to do a hop and pop it at 3000 feet.
And I,
I'm thinking to myself,
okay,
there's a limited chance that I'm going to make this exit properly.
And I think I said something along the lines of like,
Hey,
master chief,
I've never done a hop and pop before.
You know,
because we're yelling at an aircraft,
you can't hear anything.
I'm like,
Hey,
I've never done a hop and pop before.
What's anything,
any pointers?
And it was me.
And all my buddies,
none of us had done it before.
And he goes,
yeah,
he's no big deal.
You just go out,
just count to three and pull.
And I go,
Roger that.
And then he goes,
just don't Ziggy the exit.
That's what he says.
Just the exit meeting.
Don't,
don't have a bad exit.
Which like at this point,
like I said,
I was probably batting 50% bad exits cause I just didn't know what I was doing.
So of course,
what did I do?
Okay,
fine.
I'll just jump.
If I does,
they get the accident and die.
Cool.
Sophie.
But at least I tried to hit it.
So don't say get the exit to the what?
What else?
Oh,
so I went out.
I didn't Ziggy the exit actually,
you know,
that's when the,
when the pressure's on,
you rise,
you know,
you hope to rise.
I always feel better.
You know,
it's like surfing without a leash.
You know what Alicia's right.
Do you know?
I mean,
you're from Hawaii,
you know,
it's just,
I know that at least thank you.
Some people were,
at least some people don't.
When you wear it.
When I wear
a leash,
which I don't like to you fuel,
you can make mistakes and there's no,
there's no,
there's no price to be paid because all you do is you fall on your boards right
there with you.
When you don't have a rope on or Alicia on,
when you fall,
you're board has gone.
You have to swim for it.
It's a pain.
It can hit people is hazardous.
It's dangerous.
All of these things.
When I surf with Alicia and I surf like crap,
when I surf with no rope,
which I prefer,
I serve better because if you don't make,
if you Ziki that didn't use digging,
that drop,
your board's gone.
You're going to hurt somebody.
It's a nightmare.
So yeah,
thanks again.
And I'll tell you my son the other day there was big waves and I mean not big
waves from a Hawaiian standpoint,
but San Diego,
big waves and he's just on a long board.
No rope,
just dropping in on [inaudible].
I was pretty impressed.
They actually,
especially because I have a little bit of a tweak shoulder right now,
so I was wearing a leash because I can't quite grip my board as much as I need
to.
And so I was,
I'm sitting out there wearing a leash and he's out there and no rope getting
after it.
I was like,
okay,
that's cool.
Impressive.
You're not,
it was,
oh that they rise to the pressure or even in your case it seems like you prefer
the pressure.
I prefer the pressure I put from the person feels better.
Like when you drop in on a wave and there's no it,
there's no penalty for,
for making a mistake.
There's just less reward.
Right.
You want more reward.
Yeah.
I think it's like rolling with people that you're better than,
you know,
you don't want to roll with people that you're just way better than,
there's no reward to it.
You want to,
you want to feel the challenge.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
Just I do.
And that makes sense.
But I guess it's like the standard is different with youth.
Cause like I was a sponger back in the day.
For those of you that don't know back in the day,
echo is riding a boogie board.
We call it bodyboarding.
Anyway,
same thing,
thing,
leash,
no leash.
But if you're shredding big waves,
right,
you want that leash because it's some people,
I was one of those people where if you don't have a leash it's like,
okay,
I'm cutting now.
I'm thinking about that a little bit.
No,
it's on my mind.
Rather than,
you don't have to think about that.
I can just think about,
you know,
this wave shredding.
I can just think about shredding.
Yeah.
So you have that situation.
But yours perfect analogy with the g with Jujitsu guys,
like let's say you know you're a black belt and you know whatever,
you get matched up with a white belt,
boom timer goes off.
And then let's say it's a white belt that you've rolled with before.
So you,
not only do you expect to be better than than him,
you're actually actually,
you know it.
Yeah.
And there's no payoff.
So yeah,
your body is straight up,
has no essentially no motivation.
And no incentive to unquote perform same thing.
Yeah.
But I think with these types of things,
like sir,
is it just a different standard though?
Some people in
your case,
apparently you feel that in surfing with the leash,
but I think some people at the same time,
it's like wearing a mouthpiece to,
you know,
there'll be like,
oh yeah,
you know,
but that's not smart.
What not wearing without a mouthpiece.
But no,
I mean not,
not Jujitsu,
but when you start stand up.
Yeah.
It's like boxing or kickboxing without a mouthpiece in.
That's not smart,
which I've done a tone of stupidly.
Yeah.
But think of that,
that mindset there where it's like,
yeah,
I won't wear mouthpiece that way when someone hits me,
it's,
it,
the cost is greater,
you know?
So to add some pressure to talking about think dental damage damage.
Yeah.
As opposed to a face losing your boogie board and to the shore where you got to
swim a little bit more.
Yeah.
Man.
Same Deal Jack.
All right,
next question.
Boxing or Jujitsu for a seven year old boy
Jujitsu all day.
Uh,
on that one,
it's a couple reasons.
It's fun,
it's active so you can actually fight the other person and it's real fighting
and it's what they're used to.
And so many,
often when,
when parents come in and they bring their kid in for the first time,
or now it's week two,
and the parents say,
oh,
they just love it so much.
And I said,
yeah,
they're doing what they want to do.
What they're,
what they instinctually want to go look at dogs,
go look at cats,
go look at any animal out there in the animal kingdom.
You know what they do?
They grapple with each other and they,
and they actually do submissions,
right?
They,
they,
if you watch like a wolf pack,
when that dominating wolf gets the throat of the weaker wolf,
the submissive wolf,
he doesn't rip his throat out.
The guy taps out game over.
He'd now he knows that he's the alpha now,
but it's the same thing.
So,
you know,
you watch little lions or tigers,
they wrestle with each other.
They don't kill each other.
They top out,
they'd get submissive and they say,
Oh yeah,
you want,
so it's very natural and very instinctive to do so.
Yeah,
I do Jujitsu all day long.
Now it's important to develop your striking and you can do that,
you know,
training boxing on two times a week,
just get in there,
learn how to throw it.
I mean it's really,
it's really pretty sad when you,
when you meet a grown man that does know how to throw a punch,
right?
That's just not good.
They,
you should know how to throw a punch because if you get in a fight,
the fights are going to start standing.
And if,
if all you know how to do is try and double leg someone you,
you don't always want to do that.
In fact,
you prefer to knock the person out in many cases.
So learn how to throw strikes.
But I will say as far as seven year olds getting in there and sparring too
young,
too young,
all kinds of brain development still going on head trauma is head trauma.
You're not going to get better at it as you get older.
You,
you buy,
well,
I shouldn't say that.
You're not going to get better at it by taking more punches.
The more you get punched in the head,
the worst you're going to be at it,
period.
And a story,
and I shouldn't say period in story,
when you turn 18 or when you turned 17 and you're going to start sparring,
you're going to get better at it for a little bit because you're going to get
used to it.
You're going to understand how the reaction,
you're going to know how to deal with the little white fast that hits you.
You're going to,
you're going to become comfortable in that uncomfortable scenario.
But that uptick of increased improvement is very short and,
and very quickly you reach the other side of that,
which is every time you get punched in the head,
you're taking your,
your brain resilience backwards.
So do boxing,
learn it,
throw punches,
hit pads,
note,
make sure you know how to throw a punch.
And you take a kid that's 10 years old that knows how to throw a one,
two,
three combo and he gets in a street fight.
He knows Jujitsu and boxing and he's not even getting into the,
to the Jujitsu Bart cause he knows a one,
two,
three combo and he's knocking out just about every other kid or at least he's
putting them down.
Uh,
or at least at least he's shown that that kid is going to go,
wait,
this person knows how to fight and I don't because it is hard to knock people
out.
I don't care.
You know,
even a,
even a skilled boxer will have a hard time knocking out a random person in the
street cause it's hard to knock someone out harder.
So yes,
Jujitsu all day long for the seven year old and do a little bit of striking to
get them familiar with it.
Yeah,
just,
it was way funner too.
And of course that,
it sounds like a matter of opinion,
but just how he said like grappling and stuff,
the natural like even if you get two brothers who don't take to get through it
all,
no wrestling,
no nothing,
and you say,
Hey,
go play outside,
they're going to start and no ball,
no nothing.
They're going to mess around.
And chances are they're going to start,
you know,
one goes is going to be painting the other guy on the ground,
putting his hands or whatever.
And that's kind of part of the little Jujitsu.
It's like,
it's basically Jujitsu.
It's just that literally just that,
except for there's actual skills in there so they can get good at that thing
that they were doing.
And in that,
and that's one of the reasons that boxing or striking kick,
cause I should say boxing,
kickboxing,
Muay Thai,
whatever.
There's a reason why it's a little bit boring if you're not sparring because now
you're not swearing,
hitting pads,
you're hitting,
it's just not as fun.
It is cool and it's good.
And I'll tell you what,
I've been to Thailand and it's awesome seeing the young kids that are training
like that all the time.
You drive down the streets in Thailand,
just like in America,
you'd see guys shooting hoops or you see kids shooting hoops.
You see kids playing catch with a baseball.
The kids there are doing more time.
That's what they're doing and it's bad ass,
bad ass.
But that's the traditional thing.
When that's all around you.
That's what we do.
That's what else can just like soccer,
like certain places you're gonna see more people playing soccer,
playing basketball.
Yeah,
of course it's traditional thing.
But I'm saying even at that young age,
they do find it entertaining and they,
and they are also our ways to spar.
If you can do it correctly,
that is like light sparring.
It's almost like you're playing tag,
I call it playing tag.
You can kind of play tag with the person,
you are improving your skills but you're not getting head brain trauma and that,
and that's actually a good point because you do,
even if you're not trained in bucks and you'll do that in anyway,
you know,
with your brothers like slapboxing slap box.
We used to go before actually took Jujitsu when we just watched UFC where the
hoists Gracie videos,
we'd um,
we'd play slap MMA basically.
So it slap boxing,
you can kick them in the legs or whatever.
And even if you get them on the ground,
your ground upon is just slapping them in the face.
Like we do that and that's fun.
Even if you don't know Jujitsu or boxing or anything.
So that's right.
I think that you're right about that.
In that case where you just have to be careful of kids getting hit.
He kids and adults getting hit repeatedly in the head with legit strikes.
It's just not good for you,
period.
Yeah.
And that's kind of a slippery slope too,
when you're like,
oh,
seven year old boy,
um,
I want to get them into boxing,
you know?
So obviously there's a spectrum there.
It's a,
it's an a,
you know,
on one side you're like,
okay,
just get them learn,
learn how to throw one to learn the,
you know,
what else is important to say too,
because I just thought of this as you said.
Did you say there's a spectrum,
there's a spectrum.
There's a spectrum of natural ability to take punches too,
right?
So some people can get punched their whole lives and they're fine in the head.
And you look at some pro boxers that come out of their box and career after
having wars,
and they're,
they're,
they're cognitively fine.
And there's other guys that go through their careers and they're there.
They're in rough shape when they get done,
they have a pugilistic brain syndrome.
I forget the actual name of it,
but they have,
you know,
the,
the boxers,
brain damage.
And so you don't know who's going to have that.
You don't know if your kids are going to have that or not.
So if the only way to find out is to test them by giving it to him,
that's not a good way to find out.
It's not worth it.
Even if they wanted to be a pro boxer,
it's not a good way to find out because you're going to find out when they're
doing their first amateur bout and they get,
if they get knocked out or you know,
they get bad headaches,
it's a bad situation.
So I think that's one of the reasons why I think Jujitsu and wrestling is going
to get even more popular because as you look at the UFC evolve,
the people are now saying,
you know,
all kinds of UFC fighters are saying,
hey,
I'm not sparring.
You know,
I'm barely sparring anymore.
I don't spar before my fried rice bar.
Very limited amount.
And so as people are saying that,
well,
what are you going to do if you're not sparring while you're hitting pads?
That's cool,
but how are you going to train?
You're going to do Jujitsu,
you can do wrestling,
you're gonna do grappling.
That's where you're going to win the fight.
So I think that as the UFC gets more and more popular and as more information
comes out about traumatic brain injuries that come from repetitive hits to the
head,
I think that the popularity of boxing and striking training is going to go down.
And that will force or
cause the popularity of wrestling and Jujitsu to go up.
Yeah,
potentially.
true.
But these,
um,
oh,
what I said about the state,
I mean everything's really a spectrum,
but the approach to it,
right?
So let's talk about boxing.
Seven year old boy boxing is,
there's a spectrum.
On one side of the spectrum is,
yeah,
let's have them learn the one to have learned a jab,
hook,
cross all this.
And that's cool.
Hit submit,
do workout,
do some jump rope.
And do this on the other side,
the extreme side,
deuce kid discipline,
seven days a week he's going to be the next,
you know,
Roy Jones jr or something like that and we're going to start them right now kind
of thing.
So in that case,
most of the time I would predict is that on the extreme case,
the boy is not going to take to it as naturally,
you know,
unless it is part of the tradition or something like that.
But you do too.
Like I said,
it's like just,
just so unless you're doing,
you're being that guy,
that parent,
you know the ones who you're going no matter what.
Um,
but I,
I think so.
I think you're,
I think naturally they're going to take to something like Jujitsu.
It's just way more fun.
And even just the traditional atmosphere of Jujitsu is more fun.
You're just,
especially in the kids,
probably those kids
so much fun in there.
They don't barely know that they're doing something instructional in a lot of
cases.
They're just,
hey,
you hold this person here with your knees on each side.
Well,
that's the mountain.
And the personal,
the kid on the bottom is learning the amount of scape.
They don't even know it,
but they're learning it.
Yeah.
That's fine.
My daughter doesn't even want to leave the gym now.
That's so lucky.
Can just run around and think about too.
You're in a padded room.
Here's a padded room.
Do whatever you want.
Yeah,
go
the best.
Next question.
Cool.
How'd you read books to prepare for podcasts?
How do you read a book to extract maximum benefit?
Any advice on keeping yourself focused and being patient while reading books?
So this was a series of rear
recurring questions that were about kind of how I read and I grabbed three of
them that were in there.
So how do we prepare for the podcast?
It's actually a pretty in depth situation.
So first thing I'd do is read the book.
It hasn't written the book.
I highlight anything that I find to be interesting or informative to me or
reinforced an idea that I know or bring a new idea to bear.
So as I'm going through,
I'm just highlighting everything and when I get done with,
and now just to just to say when we're talking Max benefit when I was in college
and I would do that,
I would once I got done with highlighting the areas that I found informative or
important than I would make flashcards of the highlighted areas.
So I was like double locking the information because when you,
as soon as I make a flashcard,
I've already got it,
50% of my book,
I read it,
I highlighted it.
It was like 25% make a flashcard.
That's another 45 or 50% and so boom now I got to do is study the Flash Card for
that last 25% the lock in the knowledge where when I go in to take the,
I know 100% I know I'm going to know every answer on the,
on the on the question.
You recall like a thing you actually recall what the flashcards?
Yes,
exactly.
You wrote the a yes,
so that's what I would do this kind of a side track when I was in college,
highlight and then make flashcards of what I highlighted now for the podcast.
What I do is once I,
once I read it and highlight it,
now I go back through and I look at the highlights and now I start being
selective of what is going to be in the podcast and I actually circle the actual
words.
I'm going to read with a red pen that I'm holding right here and that's what I
do.
I circle and then I have little notes that say next,
like when I circle a section and then I'll either have an arrow that goes to
another point or I'll have a little note that says go to page 49 and then
there'll be a tab,
one of those little yellow sticky tabs on page 49 boom.
There it is.
I can flip right there real quick so we don't have to edit,
we don't have to.
There's a flow where it can keep rolling.
And then on top of those,
when I get to,
when I read something and I want to say something about it,
I have little sticky notes that I put in there,
either sticky notes,
I have the sticky tape stuff,
which is pretty legit and I just rolled,
I rolled that out and I stick it on there and I say,
hey mentioned,
you know,
experience I had here or what happened when I was doing this.
And so I kind of make those notes in that way I can get it done.
And while I'm doing that is when I have to figure out the chronology that I'm
going to read it because I don't always read the notes from the book on the
podcast in the same order that they are in the book.
Because sometimes it just doesn't make sense.
Sometimes there's some.
So at the same time I'm doing that,
I'm going back and figuring out what direction I'm actually going to read them.
So sometimes my conclusion of the book is different than the author's conclusion
of the book.
So I got to go back and say I got to go back pages or forward or whatever.
So that's what I'm figuring out there as well.
So that's Kinda what the podcast prep looks like.
Now,
how to stay focused in patient while reading books.
This is really difficult.
I don't have a long attention span when I have a lot of contention span.
It's only because I absolutely force myself to do it.
Hmm.
So what I would prefer to do is to read in small chunks.
I want to do work for like an hour at a time.
Right.
When I'm writing,
I want to work for about an hour.
When I'm reading,
I want to read for about an hour after that I want to get up and break something
or throw something or lift something or run somewhere.
You know what I mean?
It's,
I have an hour of patients with me.
Of course.
Unfortunately that is not enough time.
You know,
especially when you're doing a podcast a week and you've got to read a whole
book.
Well guess what?
You got to,
you got to read for longer.
You got to read for two,
three hours at a pop.
Uh,
I'll try and make it that I do on our early in the morning.
Sometimes when I'm behind the curve,
I will read first thing in the morning before I work out because I just want to
get an hour done.
Then I get to go and release,
right.
Then I get done with the workout,
take a shower,
now I'm going to read for another 45 minutes.
Okay,
good.
Now I'll do something else,
little prelaunch reading.
So,
and then before I go to bed,
I'm doing another hour.
So there I just got four or five hours in a day without having to sit down and
do something for four or five straight hours,
which bothers the hell out of me.
The other thing you can do,
and I do this,
is I'll read multiple books at the same time,
which is,
which is an interesting task,
I a tactic.
I don't know if everybody should do that or could do that or would want to do
that,
but sometimes one book,
it's boring,
but I know I got to read.
So I guess I have two books,
three books all sitting there and I'm reading them all at the same time and that
makes them a little bit more interesting.
And the last thing I would say about trying to be focused on inpatient when
you're reading books is to try to really understand what it is that is happening
in the book.
Not just from a plot perspective,
but from a human perspective.
What is that person going through?
What is that like for that person?
What are they thinking?
And I get to a point where I'm so engaged,
I feel like I'm becoming the off.
I feel like I'm in the book sometimes when I'm reading it.
So that is another good way to keep it engaging.
Because if you're seeing it from the outside and you're not really in it,
well then it's not.
It's just not as engaging.
Simply put,
if you get into it and you start thinking about that person,
you go back,
you know,
do a little Wikipedia search on the author and see who they are.
That gives you like a little insight and that helps me.
Now I connect with them.
I know that they're from New Jersey.
I know that they went to this college.
I know that they played soccer.
So now when I'm reading about them and going,
oh yeah,
that must,
oh you know,
so I try and get a little background on that person gives me a little bit more
engagement.
That's that.
That's my reading habits.
It's kind of advanced and it makes more sense.
I think that like how you say you want to put yourself in the guy's head.
You know,
actively,
I'm going to consciously put myself in the,
in the guys that sometimes people are so good at writing where you,
that just happens naturally.
But when you do,
when you do that,
it's like you can kind of get,
you get the story of course.
But
most of the time you,
when you do that all the time,
it's lessons learned.
Like what do you learn?
It's almost like when you're in your head is in it like that.
All the lessons are just flying into your brain,
you know?
Cause it's almost like you're doing,
like you're,
you're going through that war,
that particular ambush or something like that.
And then,
you know,
they talk about the mistakes and all that.
But you feel that mistake.
Yeah.
And also
I have some experience with what they're talking about.
Oh yeah.
I'm not saying,
I mean I'm,
I'm telling you right now,
I don't have even close to the experience of the books that I'm reading on this
podcast.
These guys that were in the battle of Iwo Jima and the battle of the bulge,
no,
nothing.
I did compare to anything that they do.
But do I know what it's like to be waiting to go into a bad situation?
Do I know what it's like to be shot at?
Do I know what it's like to have,
you know,
have guys getting wounded?
Yeah,
I know what that's like.
So that's a little connection too.
But I think you know,
everybody that's been in stressful situations of any kind,
you can say,
oh,
what must that feel like?
Hey,
I know what it's like when I was waiting to,
you know,
go in for a job interview.
And I was completely stressed out and that's what this guy must be feeling right
here.
Our only even worse.
So then you make that little Mecca,
mental connection is a little mental leap and you can look like you said,
you can then learn more from it.
Yeah.
Which is important.
So if I'm going into this particular situation,
you know,
in a book I'm reading it and I'm not as engaged as maybe I could be.
This guy goes through Xyz experience.
I'm looking at it from my opinion like well I could handle that,
you know,
kind of thing.
But this guy is the type of guy who that's may be part of his weakness or
something like that and vice versa where you know,
like I don't know,
something about claustrophobia.
I might be like,
Dang.
But that cluster for it will be a part of it.
Part of the story isn't necessarily a huge part of the lesson that you're trying
to get from it.
You know?
So you might miss,
there might be some disconnects there if you don't cause they have a certain
intention and you have a certain intention.
So if it's true,
the lesson lessons learned,
you might miss some of those lessons.
Just the feeling for sure.
Missing for sure.
I'm not going to get everything out of a book.
That's why when you,
that's why when you get a really good book,
you read it multiple times and you can get more out of it every single time that
you read it.
No doubt about that one.
You know it's true.
Next question.
Is it okay if extreme ownership sometimes feels inauthentic?
Example,
taking ownership of something,
not really your responsibility.
When does extreme ownership become excessive?
Self-Blaming okay,
so again,
this was two questions.
There was multiple questions like this on the interwebs.
If extreme ownership fuels inauthentic or if you're taking ownership of
something that's not really your responsibility.
So yes,
there,
there is a chance that you're going too far.
However,
the chances are is that there really is something that you can do about it.
And too often people say,
well,
you know,
it's just,
it's just something I couldn't control,
for example,
right?
There's things that you have zero control over,
And you could easily just say,
hey,
that we couldn't control
that and therefore I can't take ownership of it for,
for like for instance,
if we were planning an operation and the weather went bad and so now our
vehicles got stuck so we can say,
hey,
you know,
whether it got bad,
there's nothing I can do about it.
And that's,
people say,
well,
yeah,
you can't control the weather.
No human being can control the weather.
Well guess what?
You could make that excuse and be okay with it.
Guess what else you could do?
Hey,
I didn't have a good contingency plan for bad weather,
for rain.
We should have brought tow ropes with us.
We should have brought a winch with us so we could get out.
That's what I should've done.
I should've.
So yes,
even though it's really easy and it's like a 90% to just say,
hey,
it was bad weather or nothing I could do about it.
You could do something about it.
And,
and that's when,
when you start making those excuses,
they,
they're going to hurt you.
The same thing in the business world,
right?
Oh,
well,
you know the market,
we can't,
I can't control the market,
right?
The market went down,
we weren't expecting,
could go down and now you know,
there's nothing we can do about it wasn't my fault.
Oh really?
Because what you could've done was diversify your income streams,
right?
You get a diversified your income stream.
So you weren't riding 100% on this one segment of the market and now you're
suffering.
But all you do is say,
well,
you know,
not my fault.
You know,
we can't control the market.
The market went down.
Well actually you can control your position,
right?
You control how you were set up strategically.
You didn't do that.
So when you do those things,
it's,
it's generally there is something you could have done about it.
There's generally something you could've done about it.
And so if it feels inauthentic,
sure.
Question Yourself,
but then say,
okay,
what could I have done about this?
And I would say this,
even when you're with your troops and you say,
look,
I didn't have full control of the market.
We,
I should have done this a little bit better.
We should have planned to diversify our income streams better.
I didn't do that.
Here's where we're at.
Here's what we're going to move forward.
The guys aren't going to say like,
Whoa,
hang you out to dry because you took ownership of that thing.
They're going to realize,
look he jock has taken ownership of that.
That's cool.
We did get shafted by the market and oh well lesson learned we're going to move
forward.
But when you just come in and say,
hey,
market went down,
not my fault.
You lose respect to your guys.
So no do that.
Now all that being said,
is there situations where,
or are there situations where extreme ownership actually does become excessive
self blaming?
And the answer is yes because there are certain situations where they're
actually is nothing that you could do.
So for example,
and this is a great example,
speaking of lessons learned from the book company commander that we just went
over on the podcast,
Captain Mcdonald's,
they got assaulted,
buy
like basically the entire German army and they were left to try and hold the
line with pistols and rifles against tiger tanks.
Right?
An 88 millimeter guns and thousands and thousands of troops attacking them.
He could not have stopped them.
That you cannot stop a division of soldiers with a company of soldiers.
You can't do it.
Especially when they have artillery and they have tanks and you don't have any
tank support.
It it's,
it's,
it's an unwinnable situation.
So for him to continually blame himself and say,
I should've planned better I could he could he say that?
Sure.
He did what he did with the information that he knew at the time.
If he would've known it was a division attack,
they would have set up differently.
He thought he was just setting up a typical defensive perimeter.
Right?
So can you get to a point where you're blaming yourself excessively?
Yes,
you can.
And you,
you do need to be somewhat cognizant of that.
I'm going to tell you,
those cases are extremely rare,
extremely rare.
Most of the time you have a lot more control over your own destiny than you
think you do.
And the worst thing you can do is continually say,
you know what?
This is one of those rare instances where I had no control.
It's probably not probably an instance where you did have control,
so keep it in the back of your mind,
but keeping the front of your mind ownership
seems like excessive self blaming.
That sounds like,
you know,
maybe someone who's fully blaming themselves and then like instead of taking
action to implement corrective measures,
something like this,
they're like,
I suck.
And maybe they go into a depression or something like that.
Yeah,
the gun shy,
I know what you're getting.
Yeah,
absolutely.
They dwell on it,
right?
They dwell on the mistake.
They dwell on the fact that things didn't go their way.
They dwell on the fact that it's their fault and now they're,
like you said,
gun shy.
That's great.
Up indecisive people get indecisive,
so no.
Yeah,
those are great points.
You definitely don't want to do that.
Excessive ownership where it gets to a point where it turns you into a,
an indecisive person that's not going to make decisions because you're scared
you're going to fail.
You don't trust yourself anymore.
And yeah,
that's a great point.
That is excessive.
What you need to do is say,
okay,
this was the problem,
this was my fault.
Here's what I'm gonna do to fix it.
I'm going to move on.
We can't dwell on the stuff that happened in the past.
Can't do it.
Great Point.
That,
um,
how you,
you know,
how early or how you've kind of started this where if you,
if you,
let's say,
okay,
the opposite.
Let's say you're a blamer,
right?
You're like,
oh,
something goes wrong and you blame someone.
If someone's blaming me for something,
for everything,
you know,
all the time,
of course,
you know,
the defense comes up and all this stuff.
That always happens.
But after a while they build that rep as being a blamer,
you know?
Oh,
for sure.
Now just,
it's starts to automatic that you're defensive against this guy.
You don't trust them all this stuff.
But the same kind of goes the opposite.
You know,
how like,
you know,
if someone's always taking responsibility for the whole deal,
they're not blaming you at all.
They were like,
no,
it was my fault.
No,
it's my fault.
They're correcting it.
There you almost,
you have a bunch of stories like this where guys are like,
no,
it's my fault.
No,
And they all want to jump in.
You know?
And so the point there is like after a while you build that rip where it's
automatic,
people will automatically not have any kind of defense or whatever.
They're automatically want to solve problems.
Yeah,
that's,
that's true to that rep man.
Building Trust is how you put it.
It is building trust.
It is indeed.
Interesting.
Next question.
What made you choose literature for your degree?
You know,
again,
I think I've answered this before probably a few times so I'll,
I'll keep it brief,
but people,
bunch of people did ask along those lines along a question along those lines.
The reason I wanted to become better at English,
and the reason I studied English in college is because I had seen the importance
of language in the military written and spoken.
So written,
you're doing evaluations,
you're writing and reading and receiving orders.
You're writing and receiving rules of engagement,
concept of operations,
awards,
field manual,
all of these things that you do in the military are written.
Either you're writing them or you're reading them.
So to be able to write well and to be able to read and understand well is very
important.
On top of that,
the spoken word,
you're doing briefings,
you're giving op orders,
you're doing interviews,
or you're getting interviewed,
you're even doing like interrogations.
All of these things are spoken word.
So the better command you have of the English language,
the better you're gonna be at those.
And furthermore,
in that book that we read,
the Armed Forces officer,
1955 edition,
I think it is,
they,
I don't have the quote on me,
but leadership is communicating.
That's what it is.
It's communicating with other people what the idea is,
what the goal is.
So communication is the use of words.
So the better you can use words,
the better job you're going to do as a leader.
And that's what I realized when I was,
had the opportunity to go to college and got to pick my degree.
That's why I picked it.
Pretty simple.
Dig It.
Also,
it seems like when these,
once somebody,
your boss or your leader in whatever capacity,
you know,
like when someone misuses a word like,
or they'll say like they'll say Irregardless,
you know,
you don't want it.
Something that like you,
you totally said that wrong after a while.
You kind of like that feeling that God disrespect this verse.
Well
the guy,
he goes out on Facebook rant,
even if he's not your boss or something,
he's on a Facebook or whatever [inaudible] it goes on this rant,
but then he's like misusing your in your,
you know,
or,
or failing to put a period.
So,
you know,
it's like you almost,
it's almost like you have that feeling like you can't take him seriously.
You want them to take you,
which is important.
Yeah,
it is definitely important.
I mean not cause technically,
I mean really how much bearing does that really have?
If the idea is sound,
but it just seems that at the same time it does.
And I'll tell you one thing,
I'm not a good speller.
If it wasn't for spellcheck,
I'd spell all kinds of stuff wrong.
Yeah.
But see he never studied spelling.
Cause when I was a kid I wasn't,
cause that's when you learn to spell I think was when you're a kid.
I didn't pay much attention to spelling or never have.
So just the fact that you care though,
that's like the major part of it.
You know,
you're like okay there's spell check.
Yeah.
And one thing that's cool is by the way,
you don't need to major in English to get good at writing a good,
a good a communicating.
You can major in anything as long as you be nice to take a couple courses
though.
Cause when you do start diving in,
and I'll tell you Shakespeare's a big one,
when you start diving into understanding Shakespeare for real,
you really learn how to read well.
You really learn how to read well.
And when you submit papers that are being graded by somebody that is a
master with grammar and they're picking you apart,
you learn how to write better,
there's no doubt about it.
And so that's why I enjoyed both those,
both those aspects,
both reading and truly understanding stuff and writing and be graded in such a
way that someone's saying,
hey,
you didn't need to use this word.
You could have shortened this sentence.
And,
and basically everyone's goal is to make things cleaner and shorter.
Most of the time clarity though is to me the most important factor.
I want to make sure that what I'm saying is very clear.
So yeah,
English,
I took a class called advanced grammar and syntax dig it and I just,
I just,
I would've,
I would've taken,
you know,
multiple classes if they had,
they only had one.
Those all you,
yeah,
yeah.
That was one of the best things I,
I did was when,
cause my guys had to write evaluations.
The guys,
my subordinate leadership would have to write evaluations when I was at the,
it happens my whole career,
but once I became an officer,
but when I was at the training command,
I had a hundred guys or so,
probably more than that,
but everyone had to have an evaluation written.
And so it was the senior guys,
the senior leader,
my subordinate leadership,
my direct subordinate leadership that would write their evaluations.
And so if you didn't police these guys up in the get go,
there'd be issues.
So I brought him in and I said,
hey,
bring me your best evaluation of your best guy.
And so they brought them in,
we put them up on the screen and I'd murdered.
I murdered them all and it was so good because they all got so much out of it.
You probably need to go through that drill like one time,
maybe two times of someone murdering your writing because all you do is you
start off,
you just read their sentence to them.
That's all you do is just,
you just read their sentence,
just what they have written and read it.
And they go and you say,
is that what you're trying to say?
And they go,
no,
I just stopped.
Stop.
You know,
we'll,
I'll go back.
Because a lot of times when you read something aloud to yourself,
you recognize how jacked up you wrote it.
Yeah.
So that's like lesson number one in writing with more clarity.
Just read your sentences and see what they sound like.
So you can't really read your own though,
right?
Because when you read your own,
you know exactly what you were saying,
you know you can read your own butt and that will be helpful.
But yeah,
sometimes you'll already have an idea in your head so you won't get the full
benefit of having someone else read it aloud to you remember the last picture.
So yeah,
English is definitely important and it is fun too.
I enjoy one of the odd things,
like for Twitter,
I have fun fitting something into 140 characters.
That's enjoyable to me.
I know that's like a twisted thing.
So like a little puzzle.
Yeah,
it's a little puzzle.
And now walk up work,
could I use it?
Maybe I could pick a kid in there.
That's kind of fun for me.
Like there was something that had that kind of fun in some of the English
classes that I took where I was trying to just get the perfect words.
And so there's a little puzzle to,
it's a lot of fun.
It can be fun.
It can be fun if you have that type of personality.
Yeah.
Interestingly you're not,
I don't find you to be a grammar Nazi.
No,
I wouldn't say I'm a grammar Nazi much because I just don't think I'm an overt
grammar Nazis.
I think.
I think I find it,
I think I kind of just say,
oh yeah,
that's,
that's poorly written
code myself.
I mean,
unless it's someone that is going to turn something in and I just have to say,
hey man,
this is not good.
So which technically that's not being a grammar Nazi grandma.
Nothing was like me.
And you are,
I'm telling you about,
you know,
you get through something or be the beach and you're like,
you know I correct you.
Yeah,
I don't,
yeah,
I don't do that a lot because you know why partially then not only is it not
cool,
but it's a conversation.
Right.
Yeah.
And I was going to say something about like being informed the streets,
which is a major exaggeration cause I'm not from the streets,
although I spent some time in the streets.
But you know,
I,
I enjoy language.
Right.
And so when somebody speaks in properly,
I actually like it.
It's a different,
it's a different thing.
I mean,
even Cormac Mccarthy,
probably my favorite writer,
he doesn't,
he does all kinds of crazy things.
He doesn't use a lot of punctuation.
He doesn't use quotes.
So you're dealing with a whole nother ballgame.
I'm not slamming him and,
and,
and honestly,
it makes it harder in many cases.
It makes it harder to read what he's written.
Yeah.
And He,
you know,
people say,
well,
he says,
you know,
that it,
it should,
you shouldn't need quotations.
So sometimes you need them.
Yeah.
But I'm not going to sit here and criticize core Mac.
Do it brought that makes so much that I never thought about that.
How you,
how do things actually where yeah,
you like it.
Like there's these means and they're the,
their sole funny.
We're able to just have a picture,
maybe familiar,
maybe not,
and then it'll have like some,
you know,
a little thing on top of it,
like how,
how or when she goes through your phone,
I don't know,
something like that.
And a lot of those memes are just no grammar.
No,
it's almost like it's just an ignorant person wrote it,
you know?
And it makes it way more funny.
So overall the point there is like people talk talking pigeon or something like
that or with a crazy accent,
their English doctor,
it can be more enjoyable experience.
It's a more in depth experience for sure.
And so there's that.
Um,
and uh,
but at the same time there are a few,
there's certain situations where if you misuse a comma or misuse or don't put
quotes or something like that,
you can literally say something different then there misunderstandings can kind
of creep in.
People ask me about,
I hate to bring this up right now cause this is just like a blood bath argument,
but the Oxford Comma,
which you can look at in the Inter webs.
But it's basically when you say a list of things,
the last thing that you're going to say,
which normally you say and this use the Oxford Comma,
is you put a comma before that,
AMD.
And for me it makes things very,
very clear.
And the reason some people don't use it,
it came from the new,
I think it came from newspaper,
where they're trying to,
you know,
fit stuff into column and they can fit stuff in the newspaper.
So they say,
Hey,
we can get rid of that comment is not needed.
That's kind of where it started.
But it's not proper.
And a,
sometimes it makes sense,
but a lot of times it doesn't.
So anyways,
that's one small example.
And the other funny thing,
because I was talking about Cormac Mccarthy,
I'm going to say this little thing too,
because it reminded me of it.
Another thing in the success magazine interview or article wasn't interviews an
article.
He said,
uh,
the writer who's a good dude,
he said,
Jocko rarely does interviews.
Right?
And that's when Tim Ferriss said that two years ago,
Tim Ferriss was 100% correct.
Because I had done zero interviews so he could have said,
and he's never done an interview before.
Tim Ferriss blood would have been speaking the truth.
And he was at the time since then,
I don't know how many freaking interviews I have done.
I have done interview upon interview upon interview about an interview.
It's ridiculous.
And I put in my little Facebook rebuttal to the argument or to,
or my,
my comments about the or corrections to the article.
I said,
I actually do interviews all the time.
If you want someone that rarely does interviews,
that's Cormac McCarthy.
Cause Cormac Mccarthy,
he doesn't do interviews.
He does.
He's got what?
I think he's done one interview in the past 20 years with Oprah Winfrey.
That's it.
20 years.
One of the most,
uh,
you know,
one of the best writers of our,
of our time living today.
You know,
is he going to come on the podcast?
Nope,
he's not.
He,
he rarely comes on podcast.
He should,
he should come on this podcast.
I agree.
But yeah,
also if you,
if you see a lot of misused grammar and you let it go and you see a lot of it,
you get better at understanding it.
You know?
You know how like,
you know how certain people,
they'd be like,
oh,
this guy's accent is too thick.
You know,
I can't understand them.
Meanwhile,
the guy next to you was like,
oh,
I heard that accent before.
Plenty Times.
You know,
my neighbor is Jamaican or whatever.
So they understand.
It's kind of like that idea,
you know,
people misusing words,
grammar all messed up.
But if you're used to that,
you're like,
oh,
I see what they're saying.
It has a lot to do with context as well,
but I'm just saying if you're familiar with that situation,
so it kind of expands your mind to allow people to use bad grammar.
That's not to say you should use bad grammar.
I'm just saying from,
from the standpoint of understanding,
I could see where you're coming from.
I'm not sure that I would like completely buy into that,
but we'll go with it for this kings down time.
All good.
Well you're right in the fact that some people can understand accents really
well.
Yeah.
And for me it depends on the accent.
So I'm accents,
I can understand,
find some accidents.
I can't.
Yeah,
and it has to do with what,
what you're familiar with.
Yes.
Yes you are correct.
Next question,
Jocko.
What do you think about mechanical warrior robots in the seal teams?
Again,
this is,
this is a question where people ask me this because there's weird hype and uh,
what's the word,
conspiracy type attitude about,
you know,
artificial intelligence and robots and all that.
And so my thoughts are robots like war fighting robots.
Awesome.
Let's build the most awesome destruction robots and let's build an army of them
and let's let him get after it.
I think it's awesome.
You look at what's happening right now with drones and unmanned air vehicles.
That's where we're going in another,
I forget the name.
I mean,
I forget the specific timeframe,
but in 10,
20,
30 years,
there's not going to be anymore manned fighter jets,
military fighter jets.
So why would you do that?
You can put a computer in there and you can fly it from the ground or you can,
you don't even need to cry it.
It'll do what your mission that you want it to do.
So when we can come up with a robot that a terminator robot that can go and
attack and take care of the problem,
yeah,
let's do that.
I support it.
I hated the whole idea that robots will turn against us.
We'll build better robots that will kill those robots.
I'm not worried about that.
Fight the robots.
Yeah.
I don't care.
I say bring it on.
Bring on the robots.
Yeah,
I'll cross you.
Yes,
tiff.
I know Joe Rogan give you freaking out about some robots,
you know,
and I think you know,
pretty much everybody,
I'm probably the ignorant person here,
right?
Because the smart people like Elon Musk and Sam Harris,
they're all,
you know,
you gotta watch out because this artificial intelligence is going to become
smarter than us.
And then when are we going to do,
it's going to attack us and control us.
Yeah.
There are things.
If,
if,
if it winds up that they ultimately figure out and they won't be wrong,
that's the,
that's the view.
If they figure out that they don't need us,
then the logical thing would be to eliminate us like,
like everybody and everything does ever,
you know,
I got to admit like that sounds pretty cool.
I say bring it.
I want that robot war.
Let's get it on.
Well typically robots,
I mean we say unmanned.
Hey,
I got a question for you.
How about we unplug them?
Right.
Cut Their power source.
Yeah,
but typically,
I mean even that when you,
you know,
I don't think it,
I think there's,
I think that's a simple thing for a robot.
If they're smart to understand,
oh,
they might very well cut our power source,
so they're going to figure that out pretty quick.
I would imagine if they're turning,
but I liked the way Sam Harris described artificial intelligence one time
though.
He said,
imagine that you,
that I ask you a question and then you have a year to go and research and come
up with the perfect answer and then you come back and you answered that
question.
But it happens in a millisecond.
That's what a computer is gonna be able to do.
Yeah.
And that's pretty awesome.
And do they end up then and I don't,
I,
you know,
I'm not a,
I don't even know what you'd call a person that fear rises about this kind of
thing.
I'm not one of them,
but that's pretty unbelievable.
And it'll only get faster and better from there.
I just think that,
I don't think it's too hard to control to put controls in there that prevent the
turning of the robots,
like preventative mechanisms.
Well you talked about unmanned stuff and you know what I'm about to make a
movie,
reference it,
elbow cop,
robocop,
old school.
I think the story of that had some kind of a mechanism there.
Directives that derived from direct prime directive wasn't allowed to kill.
Wait,
what's this?
A prime directive.
What's that?
From death from robocop.
I think so.
I know they're up.
Uphold the law,
protect the incident.
I'm not doing it in an order.
Um,
something about trust.
See,
if you were Ai,
you'd be able to come back with a perfect answer.
I know,
but you program in that you can't hurt humans or whatever.
Right?
Whatever.
Like I over this thing,
let's,
this is another situation.
Let's see where it goes.
I'm good.
Rock and roll.
What the unmet that,
I mean,
it's based on like patterns,
you know,
so the unmanned thing,
usually you're not going to find something that's really technically unmanned.
Even a drone is that unmanned?
It's just less makeup can be,
it's just less mess somebody.
Well yeah,
somebody programmed at where to go.
But you can put a drone in the sky that's going to go,
yeah,
but see what you say.
You can put,
someone's got to put them in in the sky.
Someone's got to launch,
somebody got,
so it's going to be mad.
Like the intentions of something like that first intention of something that's
going to be manned for sure.
Once you give that up,
then you're like,
okay,
Nah,
you got some problems.
Yeah.
Again,
I'm just not sitting around worrying about this kind of thing.
So I'll let Joe Rogan and Sam Harris and Ilan mosque worry about keeping the
robots in line.
You know what?
I'll be ready to,
I'll be ready to fight them if they,
if they need me bring it.
Yup,
sure.
Next question.
Unless you want to talk about robot some more.
No,
that's cool.
Okay.
Or robocop.
No.
See even robocop was man,
he was a man apartment part moment.
That big machine that the initial one that caused the problems.
Who?
Ed Two oh nine the the thing that looks like a,
it had big legs.
Two Oh nine man malfunctioning or malfunction.
You have four seconds to comply.
You have three seconds to comply.
You have two seconds to comply.
Hey,
shut it off for seven year.
Watched that Bro.
That was Dallas tenseful.
That was a harsh scene.
Oh he loved it though.
Yeah.
Savage doing
Jocko.
What's your favorite submission?
Real again,
trying to do a little rapid fire here cause people ask me this all the time.
Favorite submissions cause I gotta go plural on that one.
Bra come here and Guillotine.
Those are my two favorites.
Emissions.
I think the reason why is because they're both really effective.
[inaudible] and Nogi.
They're both really effective
from the bottom right.
You can do them from the top,
you can do them from half guard,
you can do them from mount,
you can do them from a lot of different positions.
You can do them in the street,
you can do them in Emma MMA and you can do them in Jujitsu.
So I just liked the fact that there are kind of universal positions and very
effective in every aspect of Jujitsu.
Yeah.
Those are good.
I'd go for the rear naked choke to rear naked choke for sure.
Yeah.
Those are ones that you don't,
um,
like
they're big.
They're like Granddad,
there's a few of them.
They're the granddaddy submissions.
Yeah.
And you could say ArmorLoc is one of the granddaddies I just find the community
to be a higher percentage move.
Right.
Right now?
Lately,
my last several years I've been using more straight arm locks again.
But like arm bar that is the straight arm?
Both.
Yeah,
both because all my training partners are so good at defending my computers.
Yes.
That I have to go to alternate moves.
Yeah.
Actually I surprised you the other day with a,
you were kind of like you were kind of depressed to you remember what I'm
talking about cause you like take a few weeks ago it was,
it was probably more than that,
but I remember your reaction.
Your reaction was sort of,
yeah,
like I can't believe he got me with an arm bar and I even like made it like a
comment.
Yeah.
You're getting the role like when you were going for him I like,
yeah.
And it's,
it kind of seemed like you turn up,
turn up the heat when I said Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I don't like when people challenge that Jerry shout in church.
All right.
Yeah,
those are good.
I agree.
Next question,
Jacqueline,
you discuss making sure your teams have the freedom to make strategic changes to
the plan if needed.
What if you're developing a system with your team and you begin to get pushed
back from them before you feel the core values are established.
So this is a really good question.
Once again,
you start coming up with your plan and you're already starting to get some
pushback from the boys on what it is.
Well,
what do you do?
Listen to them.
Why are they pushing back?
You know what I mean?
Maybe they have some good points.
Is that possible?
Maybe you're a little bit off base on the plan that you're coming up with or the
strategy that you're coming up with.
Maybe you're not.
Of course that's always possible to,
maybe they're wrong and you're right,
but hear them out.
You know,
if I say,
hey,
we're going to hit the target from this direction here,
and my team disagrees with what I'm saying,
well,
why are the disagree?
What's,
what's the reason for that?
You know,
how do they think we should do it today?
She think we should come in from the,
from the south,
and I think we should come from the north.
Why do they think that now if I know something is right,
okay,
and I am right,
then guess what?
I can explain it to them and they'll say,
oh,
Jocko,
we didn't know that.
We didn't know that there was defenses that we hadn't been told about to the
south and why.
That's why we should come into the north door.
We didn't know that the sun would be bad,
are back from the north.
And that's why we didn't know that at the time.
So you're right now,
if I can't explain it to them,
if our kid give them a reason why my strategy or my plan is better,
then there's something wrong with my plan or there's something wrong with my
ability to explain it to them.
Right?
So if you're doing the right things for the right reasons,
you'll be able to convince your team of the strategy or of the plan.
And if you can't,
it's a hint that maybe you need to adapt your strategy or maybe you need to
adapt your plan.
Now be advised,
this is not easy.
This is not easy to do.
First of all,
you have to get your ego in check,
right?
Because you think you've come up with a plan and you think it's the master plan.
So you,
you,
you have to put your ego in check the secondly,
you might actually have the best plan,
but maybe you don't have the ability to articulate the nuances of the plan.
And so your guys,
you get a guy that's a really articulate guy that's arguing with you on his plan
and he's actually winning the argument even though your plan might be better.
That's a,
that's a tough situation to be in.
So that means you've got to really get in the weeds.
Now,
one thing that you could do in that situation,
they say,
Hey,
I'm in charge.
Shut up.
Listen to me.
And again,
this might be a situation where you're right and they're wrong,
but if you can't articulate that properly and now you only way to do it is to
pull rank on them.
Hey,
you're going to go backwards,
right?
You're going to go backwards.
So you have to be very careful of that.
Again,
this is why it's important to,
to have good command of the English language.
That's why it's important to listen.
That's why it's important to take people's ideas and that's the thing with being
a leader.
Okay?
Have an open mind,
have open ears,
listen,
communicate and lead your team not by rank,
right?
But by being able to,
to discern and uncover and mold and shape the best possible plan in the best
possible strategy by and through understanding everyone's perspectives and
ideas,
and then taking all those perspectives and all those ideas and coordinating them
into a unified fought that leads the team to victory.
That is hard.
That is hard to do.
But the minute,
again,
the minute that I'm telling somebody,
hey,
no,
just do it my way.
I know that there's,
there's something wrong here either I'm not articulating right,
which means I should take the time because if I'm right and you're wrong,
we should be able to get there to where you see that.
Yeah.
We should be able to get there.
We could also get to a point where it's six in one half dozen.
The other right.
We could get to that point too.
And at that point,
you know what I'm going to do.
You know what I'm going to do?
We're going to use your plan.
If it's six one half dozen,
the other,
I'm going to use your plan.
Yeah.
Echo says,
come in from the north.
I say come in from the West.
We look at the pros and cons of each.
I'm going to go with your plan.
What'd you want to come in from the West?
Yeah.
Okay.
If it's,
if it's 50 50 I'm going to go with your plan.
I'm going to give it to you.
I'm gonna give you the ownership.
That's what I'm going to do.
Yeah.
Even I'll tell
you,
even 60 40 I'm probably going to give it to you.
We get to,
you know,
70 30 now you're going to see it.
You're going to see the light.
If you have any brain now,
you could also be an EGOMANIAC,
right?
Who's at my way,
my way,
my way.
Now we've got to break through that.
How do we do that?
It's not by attacking your plan,
which you're going to defend because you're an EGOMANIAC.
Instead,
I'm going to say,
well,
tell me the benefits of your plan.
Let's wait it out between the year plan and my plan.
Maybe we adapt your plan a little bit.
Oh,
I like what you did here.
I see where you're coming from.
That's a really good point.
I didn't think of that.
But also we need to consider this that I didn't.
You know we we didn't know before.
So now we got to adjust.
So those are the things that are hard.
Those are the things that are hard about being a leader.
But the best thing you can do,
open your mind,
open your ears,
listen to what people are saying.
Take it on board.
If their plan is better than yours,
great.
Use it.
If it's not better than yours.
Okay.
Articulate the reasons why.
Have the conversations with them.
Don't be scared.
It's a slick move.
I,
I didn't think of that.
You
got to build up their ego.
If they've got the big ego,
we got to flank them.
So
yeah,
that's good.
Get other people's perspectives because it can seem like a 50 50 or it can seem
like
60 40 you know,
but it can also seem like a 64 or 70 30 year plan is better.
But to them 70 30 they're planets better because of their perspective.
Let's say they,
they,
there's rats drawn down this trail.
Yeah,
I don't like rats.
But if you didn't know that,
you know,
you're like frats who cares kind of thing,
you know?
Dang.
Well you're advanced dogs would be a better thing to say.
Rats aren't going to interfere with your mission.
Dogs start barking.
And maybe they had,
they had somebody,
they read an Intel report that said there was a bunch of dogs up in this,
this,
you know,
residents to the north.
So we want to come in from the West.
And I didn't know that I didn't do good enough.
So now it's easy,
easy thing to convince me off,
right?
Yeah.
But all we have to do is have the conversation.
Yeah,
understand the perspective,
talk and communicate those dogs with teeth.
Put your egos in check or snakes.
By the way,
if you're an Indiana Jones or something like this.
Next question
Jocko,
have you encountered any gaps in the leadership capabilities of officers from
West Point or the other academy?
Okay,
so for those of you who don't know what the service academies are,
there's west point,
there's a naval academy which gives you navy and Marine Corps officers.
West Point gives you army officers.
The Air Force Academy gives you air force officers and the Coast Guard Academy
gives you coast guard officers there for years.
Their military school,
they're really hard to get into.
They're extremely competitive.
They have massive amount of tradition at all of them and they are highly
disciplined and horror.
Hard to get through.
So
you would think,
right that what I just said would produce a and a standard of very high standard
of an outstanding officer.
The fact of the matter is in my career,
it really makes no difference because there's other ways that you can have
officers,
other avenues that officers come from.
They can come from ROTC,
which is when you know you go to a regular college and you basically take
classes about being an officer and you get shown how to wear a uniform and all
that.
You can go to ocs,
which is when you graduate from college,
you go to a program for 13 weeks or however long.
Each service has a little bit different in the,
in the navy.
For me,
I went to ocs,
it was 13 weeks.
That was after being enlisted for eight years.
You know,
you can be a prior enlisted guy like me,
which is you get your commission after you've been in the military and so all
those,
I've,
I had outstanding officers or I work with outstanding officers from each one of
those commissioning sources.
I had outstanding Naval Academy guys,
outstanding westpoint guys,
outstanding ROTC guys,
outstanding ocs guys.
Just outstanding us,
great leaders.
And guess what?
I also had crap leaders that were from the academy,
crap leaders that were from west point crap leaders that were from ocs,
crap leaders that from ROTC so and crap.
And by the way,
probably the,
the biggest
example of the disparity of good and bad is prior enlisted.
So prior enlisted means that you were an enlisted grunt,
a front frontline trooper in the seal teams are in,
in the military and then you get your commission.
That's what I did.
And I had great officers that were like that.
And I also knew horrible authors that were like that.
So for me,
it doesn't really matter what your commissioning sources,
it,
it matters who you are as a person and who you are as leader.
And if you have those characteristics that make you a good leader,
if you're humble,
if you listen,
if you're dynamic,
if you're articulate,
all those things that make a good leader,
if you have them,
it doesn't really matter your commissioning source if you,
and if you don't have them,
doesn't really matter your commissioning source.
That's what I've experienced in my time.
So it is interesting.
I thought when I first joined the military,
I thought these guys that came from the Naval Academy that I'm going to work
with in the seal teams,
they're going to be really awesome because they went to four years of leadership
training and learning how to lead.
And I mean Brian stands a great example,
right?
You could hear he'd got a lot out of the,
out of the naval academy a ton.
Just the way he talked about it.
I bet that Brian Stan would be an outstanding officer if he went to the Naval
Academy.
If you went to ocs or if we went to ROTC.
It's just he's got a great you,
did he learn lessons there?
Yes,
but he had an open mind to learn those things.
And so yeah,
you know,
the,
the service academies are,
are definitely awesome and re really great tradition in all those.
But you know,
I don't think you need to go to a service academy to be a good officer.
And I don't think it really matters what matters is what kind of leader in
person you are.
Is that the kind of deal where
you just never know who you're going to get at the end.
Because some people they're really good at I,
you know,
all these people they'll get really good grades but out in the field they'd do
substandard performance wise cause cause they're good at getting good grades or
they're good at taking classes kind of thing.
Good at memorizing or whatever.
Yeah.
And then yeah,
interesting.
But you don't know what you get as a person.
Well how were they brought up?
Right.
You know,
Brian Stann story cool about how he got brought up.
he'd just very,
you could see that he,
he wasn't taught his leadership ability in my opinion at the Naval Academy.
Did he learned there?
Yes.
Did he take away a lot from it?
Anybody that heard him would probably think,
ah,
definitely would,
would love to go to the Naval Academy.
But you know,
you listened to his story of his life.
He learned a lot prior to,
he learned a lot at when he was at uh,
uh,
the TBS,
the basic school.
He just learned a lot and he had an open mind.
He was a humble guy and a hard worker.
That's what makes you a great officer,
you know,
that type of thing.
Next question.
Do smaller built dudes have a niche for sof world?
For the F F world soft world.
Yeah.
Special Operations forces.
Check.
Do you say sof?
Sof is smaller.
Built dudes have a niche for the soft world.
Any advantages,
disadvantages with fit?
Physical sizer of operators?
Well,
special ops guys come in all shapes and sizes for sure.
They are,
can be big giant monster guys and they can be little tiny,
skinny wirey guys and that's the way it is.
And they're all needed in,
in the special operations community.
If you look at your average point,
man,
you're average point man.
I said,
why re light guy that's quick and nimble and you look at your average machine
gunner,
he's a big horse of a dude that can tow it around a bunch of weight.
But also there's a bunch of skinny little guys that are carrying machine gun.
There's some big guys that walk point and that's the way it is.
So is there,
is there a niche for certain body types?
Yeah,
I mean there is,
if you're a big guy you should carry something big like a,
like a machine gun.
If you're a small guy,
you should try and be in a situation where you're carrying a little bit of a
lighter load,
like a point man or a rear security dude.
But both do both.
And there's a bunch of other,
I mean,
you know,
you look at a radio man radio is got to carry a ton of weight too.
So yeah,
there's no real,
there's no real advantage or disadvantage,
I would say.
You don't want to be that big and you don't want to be that small.
But if you are,
get some,
you know,
there's just the way it is.
There's going to be things,
there's going to be things that are way harder for a bigger guy in the seal
teams and in special operations.
And there's gonna be things that are harder for smaller guy and that's the way
it is.
So you know,
if you've got to do submarine lockouts and you're a big guy,
you're going to be in a little escape trunk,
a little six foot sphere with a bunch of gear in there.
It's not fun to be a big giant guy at that point.
No.
And when you get to the beach,
after you lock out of the submarine and you got to carry a 55 horsepower motor
across the beach into a cash site and you're,
you weigh 143 pounds,
that's not going to be fun for you.
You want that big 260 pound or to come over and throw that motor on his shoulder
and carry it into position.
So that's why you have everything at a seal platoon.
That's why diversity is good in terms of body styles.
[inaudible]
good morning.
Do you ever get edgy?
Perhaps hangry
near the end of a fast if they'll,
how do you deal with it?
I tend to have more difficulty controlling my emotions during the last few
hours.
Thank you.
Anyone that
listens to me very often,
we'll probably know what I'm going to say here.
If you think you're going to get edgy or you think you're going to get hangry,
just be of aware of it and don't get angry.
Next question.
You know what I mean?
Like,
yeah.
If you're hungry and you're frustrated because you haven't eaten and now it's
starting to get to,
you just don't do that.
Yeah.
I actually,
it's kind of like we were talking earlier about surfing without a leash or
about,
you know,
parachuting under a pressure situation where I don't know what the hell I'm
doing,
but I'm going to do it anyways and I get focused on it.
It's the same thing for me when I'm doing a fast,
I don't,
I actually enjoy the fact that I'm under some excessive stressful situation.
In fact,
I like it better,
you know?
I want to feel that and then I want to be like,
I want to say to myself,
hey,
you might get frustrated right now because you haven't eaten and your blood
sugar's low,
but I'm going to be,
I'm going to use the Echo Charles approach of a,
that's weakness.
It's weakness for me to be getting angry.
It's weak for me to be complaining cause on the tail end
of a 72 hour fast,
that's just weakness.
Not going to complain.
What are you talking about?
You don't need to eat for 30 days.
People can go 30 days without eating.
My daughter,
when she was cutting weight for wrestling this past season,
she would say that.
She'd say,
you know,
I'd be getting,
she'd say,
you know,
dad would get really hungry and then I just think people can live for 30 days
without eating.
I think I can make it through the next eight hours.
Come on.
It's not that big of a deal.
There's no reason to get hangry.
That's just an excuse.
Don't do it.
Carry on with your airborne self.
Allow you to haul.
I said this before,
there's a difference between how you feel and then how you behave.
You know.
Sure you can get hangry on the inside,
but once you start behaving like Jujitsu,
man,
get angry on the inside
trading places.
Those are pretty good.
Like that.
Very good.
Well actually now to think about it,
when I was doing deployments
back in the day,
in the 90s we watched,
there was nothing to do on a ship.
We didn't have an internet.
No one wrote US letters.
No one cared about us.
There was no,
so all we did was play spades and watch movies.
And when movies we watch,
we're on videotape because this is background and Jay,
when before cds,
before Netflix,
you have videotape and we had a crate full of videos.
And so we were watching the same,
you know,
cheesy movies over and over and over again.
Probably trading places was one of them.
So if you go cloud,
if you were to go back further in the movies,
you're not cause cause what am I,
five years older than you?
Yeah,
fuck six five or six years.
Yeah.
So I'm just five or six years ahead of you on movies.
So there's a whole bunch of cheesy movies that I actually know about that you
might not know about an equation that we're getting an overlap trading places
polices iconic.
Oh yeah,
but hangry,
right?
Karate man bleed on the inside.
Hang.
I like that word hangry,
by the way.
That's
plenty.
But that implies that you're kind of like,
oh,
I'm hangry.
You know?
Like,
like you're expressing yourself,
you know,
don't express yourself.
Yeah.
Your emotions and keep it on the end of act like a winner.
If you feel you can feel like a loser on the inside,
yeah,
you can feel hangry,
but act like don't act like that.
Don't let other people see you be all vedic like that.
It'd be like,
Oh yeah,
I haven't eaten in four days.
Whatever.
You know,
you hear this joke,
you know what I mean?
Just hey,
I haven't eaten in six days.
No big deal.
I'm going to go train Jujitsu.
What are you doing?
I think so,
yeah.
Oh,
what are you doing?
Sitting around being weak.
Don't do that.
I'll be over here doing something else yet.
So yeah,
separate,
separate your feeling and your behavior and typically when it's the fee and you
know you even have a word for it,
like we're crept up on you and I had no control over it.
No,
you identified it,
gave it a name,
everything.
And if,
I mean,
if my experience serves me a lot of times when people say like,
Oh,
I have,
I get hangry or um,
pms scene or whatever,
it's explain their common behavior.
Meaning they just let it go.
They embrace it.
That's how,
that's how it is for them kind of thing.
Please forgive me.
I'm hangry.
Yeah,
yeah,
I get like that sometimes we'll,
what are you talking about?
And you just let it go,
you know,
be like that on the inside.
Be Good on the outside.
Separate the feelings versus behavior.
Next question.
Stifle your emotions inside.
You know,
they say like if you get like emotions,
you got to like let it out,
punch a pillow or whatever.
I guess as it turns out that's not true because if you intern it,
you know how you he say stifled.
The reason I kind of say that with sarcasm is because I think that the,
for instance,
yeah.
You like you're saying people these days,
they say,
Oh,
you know you to let your emotions out.
You got to let your emotions out.
You got.
If you've got to cry,
cry.
If you and I understand where that's coming from,
and you can get to a point as a person,
if there's something that's really traumatic that's happening and all you do is
hold it in,
and I've seen guys get destroyed over that because they're not expressing the
emotions that they have.
Right.
But that's
at a big level,
right?
At a daily level.
No.
Yeah.
You don't express those things.
You keep them in shock.
That's why I say it like that.
Like I'm being kind of sarcastic,
but I'm be in serious.
Yeah.
You know?
It's just don't let your emotions out and into the world.
Keep them for yourself.
I'll own them.
Don't share them with other people.
If you don't have to.
Yeah.
Now again,
people are going to freak out that I'm saying this.
Just bury your emotions because that what happens when you bury your,
when you've got something really traumatic that you Barry,
then it eats you apart.
And I've talked about that.
I mean,
talking about things that you go through in life and,
and expressing those feelings that you have about them,
that's good.
But what we're talking about is not that what we're talking about,
his daily emotions,
little ups and downs,
little tick marks on your Richter scale.
We're not talking about,
uh,
an 8.8 on the Richter scale,
right?
We're talking about just like little twos.
And when you express those twos and threes on the Richter scale out to people,
you just look unstable.
Hangry.
That's a two.
Yeah.
Overall,
and I'm not to split hairs are nothing,
but overall it's,
it's more about dealing with your emotions,
quote unquote.
So yeah,
if you,
if a good conducive way to deal with your emotions is to let them out.
And there's all different kinds of emotions.
Like if you're sad,
if something's eating you up on the inside because of sadness or whatever and
it's conducive to your recovery development,
whatever,
to express those emotions,
then yes,
but if you're hangry and you lose your temper on your kid,
that's not going to,
you're not dealing with your emotions correctly,
so in stifle your emotion,
but it's not a really,
it is stifling them,
but before you stifle them,
you're identifying them.
You're like,
oh,
hey,
I'm hangry.
Okay.
I identified that I'm going to separate feelings from behavior that's dealing
with emotions right there,
that's dealing with,
it's a great point that oftentimes expressing your emotions to the world doesn't
improve your situation or your position at all.
Correct.
In fact,
I would say that most of the time,
expressing your emotions to the world sets you back,
and that is why I vote.
In many cases,
stifle your emotions.
Keep them in.
Don't let other people see you.
Did you put your cards on the table?
Right?
You put your emotional cards on the table.
Now you can't gamble anymore.
You can't.
You're not in the game anymore.
The person knows what's going on,
but you're giving it to him.
You're not going to know what I'm thinking.
You're going to think I'm just,
everything's cool with me.
We're training Jujitsu,
right?
If I'm getting frustrated and I show that to you,
right.
What does that do?
You're getting also you,
you just go level up.
You Think,
oh,
I got him.
He's frustrated right now.
He can't,
oh,
I'm working.
This is working against them.
If I'm just saying the same face all the time,
which is what I do primarily,
hey,
same face all the time.
Just we're,
you know,
moving the same way.
When you do get me,
I forget what you say when you get me to react to something good,
recognize the urgency.
You say you say,
oh,
I recognize a little urgency there and I always go down.
I don't want him to recognize,
I'd rather just have you just pass my guard and you're just there and we just
sit there like it's no big deal to us and not humid.
They made me get all panicky where then you level up a little bit.
And it's the same thing with life,
right?
Every time you express these big emotions to your boss or to your team,
you express these big emotions to your team.
They see all your cards.
Don't let them see all your cards.
Is this manipulating kind of,
right?
This is one of those things where people think,
oh,
transparency.
We hear that all the time.
These days.
Transparency.
You gotta be transparent.
No,
actually you don't.
Yeah know with that,
you don't have to be transparent all the time.
You have to win the game.
You know what?
Does the football coach go out and Candace playbook to the other football team?
No.
He's got to win the game in a typically no,
and that's not how you win the game.
So are we.
You know what we're doing?
We're playing chess.
It's emotional chest.
You're playing with other human beings.
You want to win.
Now,
if you're winning so that I can take advantage of you so I can manipulate you
and get something from you that you don't want to give me.
That's bad and I'm not talking about doing that.
But if what I'm doing is keeping my calm so that instead of escalating an
argument with you,
I'm getting you to see it from my perspective just by remaining calm.
That's what we're talking here.
You know,
Lave told that story the other day where it,
he tells the story lot cause it was hilarious story where I came in,
we didn't have a chance to talk to each other as he was playing in this big
operation.
And I come in 10 minutes before the operation,
I said,
hey,
let me,
let me see what you're doing.
And he kind of shows me on a map,
hey,
we're going to go here,
here in near.
And it's like,
Hey,
you should do this instead.
And he was like,
we,
we're leaving in 10 minutes.
And I said,
man,
but just think about it.
And he goes,
do you know what?
Just cancel the OP.
And he was all mad.
Right.
And,
and you know,
he's,
he's like a Jocko kind of like laughed at me.
I didn't laugh at him like a leg,
like a jerk.
You know,
it was like,
but I was like,
hey man,
listen,
just think about what I'm saying right now.
But that's the,
that's an example,
right?
I didn't show my emotions,
which was,
which would be more like,
dude,
are you serious right now?
You're going to cancel an op because we have a difference of opinion and think
about what your,
I didn't do that.
I was like,
hey man,
I get it.
Everyone's stressed out right now.
We got to leave on this thing quickly.
Think about what I'm saying.
They'll look at,
this is all I'm saying.
We could execute this in a better way.
So that's what I'm talking about.
Does that make me manipulative?
No,
it doesn't make me manipulative.
It makes us as a team do a better job.
And as soon as life saw that and he was like deescalated himself,
he was good to go.
We move on.
Yeah.
So that's what I'm talking about.
Stifle your emotions at all times.
But you know,
and,
and just to address that though,
for Real,
when you do see the big emotional impactful things in someone's life and they
don't express them,
that absolutely is bad.
And I'll tell you where you see this a lot is with kids,
you know,
kids,
teens where they,
they there something bothering them and they don't,
they hold it in,
hold it in because they don't have anybody to talk to.
They can't talk to mom and dad because mom and dad don't get it.
Their friends are the people that they're pissed off and pissed off at anyways,
so they can't tell them what's going on.
So they sit there and they harbor a lot of that anger.
And that can be,
that can be very problematic.
And it goes through all through,
you know,
adults as well.
And,
and you know,
at work sometimes people will,
they got problems at home so they can't talk to their wife because that's what
the problem was.
And they can't talk to her husband because that's the source of the problem.
But then they get to work and they don't want to look like the person that's got
problems at home.
So I'm not going to say anything there either.
And the next thing to do,
what are they doing?
They're trying to escape those problems.
How are they doing it?
Instead of,
instead of letting those problems out and talking to somebody about them,
they're having a know,
having a drink in the afternoon,
getting on the alcohol whenever they're doing something that's negative and
they're not moving forward at all.
So those are not the kind of feelings that and emotions that you want to subdue
or stifle.
But these little ones and twos and threes on the Richter scale being hangry,
get,
control those things and start stifling certain emotions ones and twos is a good
way to deal with them because when these,
cause they usually real spontaneous emotions and they'll,
and they'll,
they don't have the power to sustain.
They're just gonna they're there and then they just fade away and that's cool.
That's why.
Yes,
correct.
Then over time,
now you're good at dealing with them in that way.
When you get hangry and you've been for one year,
you've been dealing with it by just ignoring it.
You know in regards to behavior does not acting on it.
Now you're good at doing that.
Not so automatic.
Now you don't get,
you don't act hangry anymore.
Not True.
Okay.
This is part question,
part opinion.
In podcast 13 you stated effectively not explicitly that Jujitsu is the martial
art that takes the most time to become proficient.
I disagree and here's why.
As a wrestler have been able to pick up Jiu Jitsu in a matter of about two
months to the point where I can submit a blue belt here and there and mostly
control purple belt possibly.
There's white skill range along belts,
which I only wrote with lower level players.
I might just be a bad teacher,
but if not,
I have not had as much success teaching Jujitsu guys to wrestle after the same
amount of of time.
They're
after the same amount of time and there may be a low,
high,
high school wrestling level.
I found it extremely difficult to teach you discipline disciplinaries to shoot,
penetrate with their hips or effectively use their hips to defend us or
scramble.
Possibly.
My sample size is too small to form an accurate opinion,
but I'm curious of your thoughts on the topic.
Thanks.
Love listening.
So yeah,
I guess when I said that I should have said grappling in general,
which is definitely harder to achieve a basic level of competence in
rather than striking.
Now,
don't get me wrong,
you take a skilled boxer,
they will destroy an unskilled boxer.
You take a skilled Moy Thai guy,
they will destroy and unskilled Moitai do you?
You've changed good Moyie Thai people before.
The first person that I ever did that with that was a skilled Moitai legit
skilled Moitai.
It was like black belt versus white belt,
right?
Yeah.
I would think about throwing a kick at him and he would check in,
right?
And then he would throw a kick at me before I even knew what was happening right
there.
That much better.
They can see your hips.
They moved.
Same.
Same thing with boxing.
If you go against a good boxer,
they'll jack you up in that sport,
right?
In that sport you will get worked.
So
now that being said,
a good wrestler is a good grappler.
You are a good grappler and that's why you're able to pick up Jujitsu very
quickly because wrestling is grappling,
which is Jujitsu.
There are there differences?
Yes there absolutely are differences but it's like Longboard Surfing and Short
Board surfing.
If you're or or baseball and softball,
if you played baseball in college,
when you get out on the the the office softball team,
you're a killer.
That's the way it is.
Cause you played softball.
He played baseball,
you didn't play technically softball.
It's the same thing with,
with wrestling and as far as the fact that it doesn't take long to learn if
you're a high level wrestler to learn Jujitsu.
Yes,
absolutely.
You'll learn it very quickly.
Look at the history of the UFC.
Dan Severn,
Mark Coleman,
Kevin Randleman,
Randy Coachart,
Tito,
all those high level wrestles and that's the history.
Cause guess what high level wrestlers are there right now to Jon Jones.
DC.
It's,
it's wrestlers,
it's wrestlers.
And wrestlers.
Now,
are there other guys that come in and fill it?
But the,
the,
I would say the majority base is wrestling,
you know,
so
now you also have to look at,
speaking of history,
you have to look at the early UFC or you go to any gym in the fact is the fact
is a Jujitsu only guy beats a wrestling only guy in a fight nine times out of
10.
That's the way it is that now if the rest of the can learn very quickly,
but if the rest of their only knows wrestling and Jujitsu guy only knows
Jujitsu,
Jujitsu guy is going to win
simply because the rest of the doesn't know how to finish the fight.
He doesn't know how to finish it.
He doesn't have any submission Holts to finish a fight.
So can the occasionally,
nine times,
you know,
one time out of 10 or whatever get something and,
and yes that can happen,
but,
and also I'm not talking about if you take a NCAA wrestler right and you put
them against the white belt or,
or maybe even a blue belt,
there's a chance that the blue belt can't submit him for good guys.
Just too strong.
That's if he has some awareness.
If he has no awareness whatsoever,
he's going to get tapped out.
Yeah.
And if you watch the early UFC,
that's exactly what happened.
You know,
the wrestlers,
they might get positioned but they were getting choked.
They were getting tapped and you go to any gym right now,
you have a tough wrestler walk in that doesn't know any Jujitsu,
he's going to get tapped out.
I mean,
for instance,
right now at our gym,
we got a really good wrestler name Taylor Johnson,
and I'll bring his name up because it's,
I can remember it all because it's all been recent.
He's been training now for less than a year.
When he first came in,
he was getting tapped out.
You know,
that's the way it is.
He's a phenomenal wrestler.
Two months later he wasn't getting tapped out.
Six months later,
he's tapping people out.
So that's what happens.
But if you take physically kind of close people and you put pure wrestling
against pure Jujitsu,
Jujitsu is going to win.
Now there's also another thing that you're probably noticing in this situation
and that is that wrestling,
wrestling selects for athleticism,
right?
Wrestling selects for athleticism.
And for you to be competitive in wrestling,
you need to be strong,
quick,
athletic,
agile,
all those things are important.
And I've seen that,
you know,
with the,
uh,
the school where my kids wrestle and you see it,
what it's like when you get a strong athletic kid and how they're able to
execute moves better than someone that's not that good of an athlete.
And so wrestling does that.
Wrestling is selective.
So if you wrestled,
guess what?
You're a really good athlete.
You,
and if you did well wrestling or he wrestled for a long time,
you developed that athleticism because you had to be explosive if you had to
train hard.
So that's that.
Also blue belts.
You look at a blue belt,
a blue belt is basically a person that's been doing Jujitsu for a year,
maybe two years.
Right?
So that's the same thing as a lower level high school wrestler,
right?
A low level high school wrestlers.
A guy that didn't start wrestling until he was a freshman year started
wrestling.
Well that's a low level high school wrestler and guess what?
He's getting beat.
So you should be,
if you're a good wrestler,
you should be able to,
once you understand the basic principles of Jujitsu or you should be able to
beat blue belts because they're a year into the game.
That's the way it is.
Um,
yeah,
you take a competitive wrestler and you go against somebody that's,
you know,
seven years in and now there are brown belt.
Well that's,
that's a competitive high school wrestler that's a senior and he started
training in sixth grade.
That's seven,
eight years.
Go against a seven or eight year Jujitsu guy you've got,
now you've got a good match and likely the Jujitsu guys going to win.
And now again,
if you take no,
if you take a pure wrestler versus a pure Jujitsu,
the Jews,
Jesus,
God's going to win all day,
all day.
So,
um,
you know,
there's no denying and like I just said,
there's a reason that wrestling is the,
the premier skillset in the UFC that predicts champions,
no doubt about it.
It is a great and incredible martial art.
I,
I wish that that wrestling had kept his roots as catch wrestling and still had
submission holds and all that cause it would just completely change the game but
it doesn't,
so you have to add them later.
There's also something else too where I think that,
I think that people in general wrestling's not for everybody,
right?
It's a fairy hard sport and I think that people avoid that grind of as far as,
as far as the,
okay,
you're going to get good at wrestling now how much you do to guide now I'm gonna
make you good at wrestling.
Jiu Jitsu
guys,
avoid the grind.
I shouldn't say all of them,
but some
often do you do two guys avoid the grind of the take downs and the intensity of
wrestling.
They're not looking for that.
That's one of the things that make does Jujitsu appealing to a very broad range
of people is that you can train it at a,
at a mellower pace.
Right?
And that's also why if you go do Jujitsu tournaments,
wrestlers do really well in Jujitsu tournaments because they understand the
intensity of rounds of limited time of smashing someone,
of going all out,
Jujitsu guy that's been trained in the gym,
they ain't ready for that first tournament.
There's no Jujitsu guy in the gym that goes to the first tournament and says,
yeah,
that was just like what I thought it was gonna be like,
no,
they are not used to that intensity.
They're not ready for it.
So
I mean,
and,
and of course not taking away from Jujitsu guys that train like mad men with
total intensity and get after it super hard to is those guys exist as well.
And also last little thing on this,
there are also some wrestlers that don't adapt to the slower pace of Jujitsu.
They can adapt to that and they don't adapt to the slower pace of MMA.
And so they,
their whole career,
they gas out and there's plenty of pro MMA fighters,
UFC that have come in high level wrestlers that they couldn't ever quite make
the transition to MMA.
So,
you know,
bottom line,
these are,
uh,
these are points that I pretty much agree with that the,
that this,
this guy made and wrestling is awesome.
I think it's a great base.
I think it's,
it's a form of grappling and it complements Jujitsu and Jujitsu.
Jujitsu compliments it.
And I wish that it was one sport,
but it's not,
so you have to do both,
you know?
And it seems like,
like too,
because he was originally not complaining,
wasn't complaining,
but he,
his premise was that,
you know,
did you get to,
is,
is not in fact the hardest one to master,
you know,
wrestling,
he's implying that wrestling is harder to,
to master.
You know,
could because he taught Jujitsu guys wrestling and they didn't pick it up right.
It was kind of,
uh,
in Jujitsu you can break all kinds of wrestling rules in Jujitsu and,
but wrestling guys when they'll come in,
if they have to learn to break some wrestling rules,
otherwise it's going to be their detriment.
Sure.
A lot of them,
a lot of them carry over a lot of,
you know,
a lot of the strength and sit out.
But man,
if a wrestler can't break the rule to,
to go to his back,
you know,
cause a lot of wrestling,
the wrestlers will give up their back all day because they don't want to go on
their back,
you know,
and that's why they're going to get choked all the time.
But if like Taylor you,
that's good example of pro,
he'll fuck he broke that rule quick.
Yeah.
And that's why he's so good because he can expand his mind and break that rule.
So what,
consider the Jujitsu guy right now,
he has to learn all these things.
So he has to essentially,
and not so much break the rule.
You,
he hasn't probably break some rules,
you know,
but not going as back,
whatever.
But if you just look at,
it doesn't have to break any Jujitsu rules necessarily.
So
case in point,
how much time and effort am I going to put into learning a takedown correctly
when it barely decides the match?
Exactly right.
When you don't have to,
there's a mental,
uh,
gap into the desire for knowledge.
Because if I,
if you take me down,
cool,
I'm going to be a teen.
You,
I'm going to be,
you're not going to pass my guard.
Whereas when a wrestler shows up,
he has to learn this stuff.
Otherwise he's losing,
he's getting tapped out.
He,
he's getting choked.
Yup.
So that's a great,
great point there.
Yeah,
very true.
So yeah,
you'll have to,
you know,
and even when you say,
okay,
Jujitsu should focus more on takedowns and it's really cool and you should
definitely focus on takedowns and you got to learn them and it's very important.
But at the back of your mind,
as a Jujitsu Guy,
I'm like,
just boulevard.
Yeah.
I don't really care if you take me down,
it's okay.
Or,
and then now we're talking about,
in this case we're coming in saying that me personally,
cause I don't like just saying put 10 potentially,
but,
and here's the thing to even add to that,
even if you're considering the comparison of wrestling and Jujitsu,
take the takedown situation.
Take not all takedowns are quote unquote wrestling take downs.
I can be like,
okay,
I can not learn wrestling at all and still be good at takedowns if I learned
judo or if I,
you know,
if I learned something else.
So again,
so it goes,
it's basically you're taking something really vast,
a lot of easy ways to maneuver around certain techniques and still be fastly
successful.
And then you,
you're basically saying,
okay,
let's take that a person who has that approach and narrow it down to this much
more difficult approach and way less effective approach.
Essentially it's the vastness of grappling.
I can still be successful in graph grappling without learning x,
Y,
z wrestling moves and then you want to teach them these x,
y,
z wrestling moves.
Probably some that can go against you,
especially when it comes to energy,
energy conservation and all this other stuff.
That's why a guy,
maybe,
yeah,
it might be difficult to learn that,
but how you said there's a gap in the motivation.
So it's difficult to want to learn or kick or care about learning this thing
when it's going to serve me less in Mike rapidly.
No doubt.
You can just look at the human facts of Jujitsu.
There's a reason why takedowns are not emphasized.
Very much introduced to add a normal academy and normal academy.
They do not have the focus on take downs like wrestling,
wrestling,
that takedown wins.
You does it.
We need the match
automatically.
But that's a huge part of wrestling is getting the take downs.
Jujitsu.
It's,
it's a little tiny percentage of the match.
Does it give you two points?
Yeah,
but it doesn't mean anything to me cause I'm going to submit you.
Yeah.
And just the nature of the,
of the game,
you know,
wrestling is take down pin.
There's more to it.
I understand.
But Jujitsu is just submit the guy,
you know,
so Jujitsu in in a way,
it's like,
just,
just get it to the ground.
You can read off your back and you can win them from the top.
You can wear a wrestling is not like that.
Yeah.
I mean people literally pull guard and then when from their back and zero
seconds on top zero and win the match.
And so the fact that you can pull guard gives you this entire out right to get
away from doing take downs and you can still be victorious.
Yeah,
very,
very often.
Yeah.
And that goes along with these,
even these techniques that he mentioned,
like,
you know,
uh,
see hit the,
basically the,
there's,
there's a lot of moves in there.
They're big moves,
big moves,
and they do help you.
But like I said,
that they're just,
they're simply not necessary.
You know what I mean?
Any physical move is helpful to know and ought to defend,
whether it be from an offensive or defensive position.
But again,
if you're trying to narrow it down and teach these guys who their approach and
their knowledge comes from the vastness of grappling and you want to narrow it
down to the thing,
it may or may not work,
you know,
and it may or may not serve you.
It could work against you.
But here,
let's try to learn this real hard.
Yeah,
you're going to have that gap in motivation.
Actually don't care about the takedowns.
Yeah,
and I'm going to go on record now as saying this,
just because Jujitsu doesn't focus on takedowns doesn't mean that you shouldn't
focus.
You should learn take downs.
You need to know take downs from a self defense perspective,
from an MMA perspective,
take downs,
wrestling.
You have to do it.
I mean,
that's why my kids wrestle.
You know?
It's because I didn't wrestle and I hate that fact because I go against the,
like he's saying,
you know,
I go against a good high school wrestler.
I,
it's hard for me to take him to the ground.
You know,
you get somebody that wrestled in college.
I know what I know.
I'm not going to.
Now I have developed good takedown defense over the years and it's actually take
down all offense because I have offensive ways of defending the take down.
You know,
I'm going to throw submissions and stuff,
but I can't go back in time and go through the training that you get when you're
a high school wrestler and a and a college wrestler.
I can't do that.
I can't do it.
I mean,
I just don't have the time and the motivation to do it because I'm in the same
boat as,
as you know what?
The guy that you're just talking about,
how much time am I going to focus on takedowns I know I go against a college
wrestler,
he's taken me down.
I go against good high school wrestler.
There's a good chance he's taken me down.
Yeah.
So how much time and effort,
I mean,
I could spend the next five years,
I could go through a competitive circuit.
I could join the wrestling club,
but am I gonna do that right now?
Is that time effective or do I just want to get better at Jujitsu and then have
access to the rest of the grappling spectrum that you just talked about?
Will,
it's an obvious choice.
I'm going to focus on the spectrum that has the most,
uh,
the most application in every situation I'm going to be in.
Yeah.
So if you,
if you get the chance to wrestle,
wrestle as much as you can,
learn your takedowns drill,
your takedowns,
put your kids into wrestling.
Do you did to for sure.
Put your kids into wrestling.
Yeah.
They don't have to worry about it then.
The factory main thumb people,
they don't want that beef.
You know where you got to go wrestle,
man,
that's hard.
You know,
and even like a wrestling,
you can have out wrestling style to your Jujitsu,
you know?
But again,
if you,
if you don't know who you know,
who didn't wrestle,
Craig,
Craig Baker eight curse didn't wrestle.
You were trained with him.
You'll be like,
oh,
where did you wrestle in college is what should we be thinking?
He's pure Jujitsu.
Didn't wrestle in college,
didn't wrestle in high school,
didn't even wrestle in high school.
He feels like a total wrestler when you turn with him and his take downs are
great.
Yeah.
And there's some Brazilian guys that have come up that,
you know,
Brazilian UFC fighters that are very good wrestles,
that never wrestled before.
They have really good takedowns and,
but you know,
you're gonna,
you're gonna have to read it if it worked for that.
And these kids that come out of high school yeah.
That wrestled in high school.
They got it.
Yeah.
It's a little gift that work hasn't been put in yes.
Gift that they got.
But for these guys,
and back to the question for these guys that he's trying to teach,
and he totally says it could be my sample size.
I understand.
And that's a good point actually.
But um,
because the samples had to be big,
you can get guys like Craig,
they'll pick that stuff up real quick.
But at the end of the day when it comes to,
as he put it,
when it comes time to shoot,
penetrate with their hips,
are effectively use their hips to defend or scramble,
you can omit all of those things from a Jujitsu guy and he can still win and
beat vastly successful.
You know,
scramble,
scramble scrambles,
a questionable one.
Yeah.
Have to be able to scramble.
But again,
I mean you,
let me,
let me show you scrambling as a very good valuable thing to have in Jujitsu.
A much more valuable than,
you know,
being able to penetrate on the shop.
Yeah,
yeah.
I agree.
But yeah.
Wrestlers,
right.
That's a weird,
that's,
let's do an interesting,
I roll with this.
I feel bad that I forget his name,
but I rode with them every time I see him and he's swallowing me.
I'd give him maybe one 65 maybe and button an awesome wrestler,
new guy to under one year and he's giving his wrestling,
but he's like high level wrestler.
And also if I play the wrestling game and I know,
I know wrestling,
like I'm solid,
I can wrestle against good wrestlers.
Maybe not Taylor but good so I can play and I'm bigger than him,
you know.
So if I go and wrestle to wrestle this guy bro,
he like it.
He came on here.
Yeah.
He'll ride his game close.
But if,
uh,
if I just slow down in my mind be like,
okay,
he's a wrestler.
Yeah,
let's work around the wrestling.
Oh no problem.
Yeah.
You know,
but once,
once he,
if he can give up the wrestling rules,
you know,
you know how he,
he,
cause he has that FLS CISM he can switch his hips like all quick base just like,
like he's built into the ground.
That's how good his basis,
you know,
it's,
but yeah,
wrestling.
Yeah.
And I guess from a human nature perspective here,
if you were to apply this to other situations in life,
think about when you're trying to get people to do things,
think about the motivation that they have and their had not,
not motivation of like,
Hey,
let's go,
but not the actual,
the actual mental motivation of what they're going to gain from what you're
trying to give them and do they see the reason of why it's important?
Yeah,
very got apply that across the board.
Jujitsu.
Wrestling is wrestling,
grappling,
grappling is like next question.
Hello.
Do you happen to have a podcast discussing loyalty to marriage that involves
marriage to a service member?
I see many marriages,
military spouse where the service member has a great background in
Lateri but lacks marriage at home.
You know,
I actually have answered this question before,
and maybe not this specific,
but I'm going to go over it quickly just because this isn't just about military,
you know,
relationships,
it's about any relationship,
but you know from a military perspective,
absolutely.
Military relationships are very hard.
You've got time away,
you got classified work.
There's a lack of understanding of what's going on at work,
then you've got lives as deck,
right?
And with that,
the job has to come first and that's a very hard thing for people to understand
that the job has to come first.
Why does it have to come first for survival?
Because the harder you train,
the better you know your teammates,
the battery shot you are,
the better your chance for actual survival in a combat situation.
So a spouse has got to understand that,
right?
That in order for the service member to take care of the family family,
the service member has to do his utmost to prepare himself and his team for war.
The number one priority.
Now,
what the spouse has to understand is that this doesn't mean that he wants to
spend time away from his family.
He doesn't want to prioritize his team over his family.
He doesn't want to miss the recital,
doesn't want to miss the ballgame,
doesn't want to miss the teacher's conference,
but he has to.
He has to.
So spouse
don't be mad when he makes that priority except an understand that the family is
the number one priority.
It is the number one priority.
But in order to be there for the family,
he's got to prepare for war so that he can come home to his family after
deployment.
Now this,
this obviously also applies to police.
This applies to firefighters.
And I'll tell you what,
it applies really to the breadwinner,
man or wife or husband or wife in any walk of life,
right?
If you're the breadwinner for the family,
you've that,
that's what you're doing.
You,
the way that you're taking care of the family is by bringing home money so that
there is food and housing and clothing and a secure future.
That's what you're doing.
And so the,
the spouse in these situations has to understand that the hard work,
the hard work and the hours and the days and the weeks that are taken away from
the family
is actually done to provide for the family,
right?
So that's the,
the key piece that,
that people have to understand that,
that,
that the,
the spouse has to understand.
Now the service member,
and again I've,
I've talked about this before,
the service member or the firefighter or the police officer or the breadwinner,
what they have to do is they have to make sure that they don't go overboard,
that they draw the line somewhere,
that they don't destroy what it is that you're trying to protect.
Don't destroy what it is you're trying to take care of.
Don't give the plants so much water that you drown it.
Don't cook the steak so long that you burn it.
Don't work so hard for your family that you don't have a family anymore.
You got to have the balance
in.
One of the things that you've got to do is you got to explain that to the family
and you got to tell them what's up and you got to tell them that they are the
most important thing and that all this work that you're doing that's taking you
away from them is actually being done for them.
And you got to communicate that to them.
They got to understand it's hard for them to listen to hard for uh,
an eight year old kid.
Don't understand why you're missing the,
the the baseball game or watch this year old girl while
you're missing the digit three tournament or whatever.
It's hard to explain that,
but you've got to at least try.
You got to make it evident to them and you also have to make sure you don't have
viewed abuse it.
Right.
Because work work can be fun and hanging out with our teammates for an extra day
of shooting or an extra day of jumping or having a beer at the pub on the way
home,
that can also sometimes be more appealing than the recital,
then the ballgame.
So don't abuse it.
You,
you have to take care of your family and you have to talk to each other and
understand this balance together,
understand the sacrifices that are being made on both sides so that you can work
it out and maintain the strength of that entity,
the family that you're trying to take care of.
Great.
Yeah,
and I mean I walk the line on this one.
I work hard and I worked hard for my whole life.
Yeah.
And it's going to depend too,
right?
I mean like how you say don't work so hard that you don't have,
it depends how rigid or resilient like the family is.
And that has to do with like,
you know,
UX explaining and it's Kinda like lifting and overtraining.
I'm lifting so I can get these results when I rest are all this stuff.
Right.
But if I'm just living live a little lifting,
no wrath and,
but it's going to depend depending on how strong I am to begin with kind of
thing.
So I mean,
yeah,
man,
make sense.
You know,
it's,
it's helpful when you got to explain it though.
Like how you say with everything,
just keep explaining about my daughter yesterday,
last night asked me why she wasn't sad or nothing like that,
but she's like,
why do you work so much things?
I mean,
let's face,
I don't work so much,
but as far as she's concerned,
if I'm not playing with her at that moment or your work to me,
I can work one minute.
She's like,
I work too much.
But I was like,
Oh Dang.
I had to think of it from her perspective,
you know?
And I explained it,
I explained it all and she had fun me explaining it,
you know,
and now she understands.
I had,
uh,
you know,
I was like,
Eh,
sitting,
having dinner with my,
with my family,
you know,
and we don't eat together every single night cause we're all busy doing a bunch
of different things.
So we were having dinner and for some reason I had something going on.
It's business where eyes pulled out my phone and I was texting someone going
back and forth and you know,
one of my kids was,
you know,
why you on your phone right now?
And then you know,
my like wife chimed in.
Yeah,
I can't,
you just put that down.
And I said,
hey,
just so everybody knows,
did you get defensive?
I did get a little bit defensive.
I said,
just so everybody knows if I could,
I would take this phone and throw it in the ocean and never look at it again.
But I have work to do and sometimes my work involves working at night and some,
and most of the time if I'm working at night,
it's on this little gadget right here that I have to look at.
So that's why I'm doing this.
Not because I don't want to listen to you and not because I don't want to sit
here and just focus on the family right now.
But guess what I got work to do and the work that I'm doing is not for me.
It's for this family so we can have a house so we can have food on the table.
Okay,
so back off.
But they got the point,
you know what I mean?
I didn't really yelled the back off point,
but they understand,
they realize,
you know,
and for you know,
for my,
for my young daughter that wasn't there five years old at the time,
I said,
this is how we get food and this is how you get toys.
I have to work to buy you toys.
Yeah.
You know,
do you not want any more toys?
She was like,
no,
I'm good.
Go ahead and answer the phone.
Did you have work to do?
Yeah,
tha tha tha that's why you have toys.
That was part of my speech too.
There you go.
That was it.
All nuts though.
You didn't get nuts like I did.
It wasn't very confrontational.
She's like smiling.
She is,
she is a good conference.
Keep in mind when I'm working,
she has the option to jump on my lap.
Right.
Keep that in mind.
So it's,
it's,
this isn't a troublesome situation and I understand that,
but the point still is there though.
You explain it.
Okay.
Like you explained it or like how I explained it and if they know and they
understand that,
it's like,
it's clear,
you know,
but not,
that's not to say that they don't have a point though,
because sometimes,
especially if you don't explain or you're not engaged at all these people who
yourself,
you need to check yourself and make sure that you're not going overboard,
then you're not abusing it because you know what,
as does that client really need to hear from me at this moment?
Yes.
The answer is,
and this is,
you know,
I figured out years later,
it's like,
no,
actually they don't need to hear from you right now.
Yeah.
Not all the time.
Sometimes yes,
sometimes,
but they can hear from you a little bit later after dinner.
Yeah.
When I text you right back,
you have to respond right back.
Yeah.
No,
you have to respond to that.
One of them busy.
Crazy.
We got a diaper one morning shake.
No,
we don't,
but we're gonna do that anyway.
Jocko,
do you have a specific place or time you spend thinking specifically about your
fallen comrades?
Yeah.
Anytime that things are going
good,
then my life.
Any moment of happiness.
Okay.
Anytime I'm enjoying my life from thinking about
what the future holds,
that's when I think about my friends
that died.
So
surfing after a good wave and waiting for the next one
after some good jujitsu training after a good workout or a good meal,
or maybe a smile or a laugh with a friend or having an ice cream cone with my,
with my daughter
or playing guitar with my son,
or catching up,
catching a little smile from my wife
at those moments,
at those moments.
Without a doubt.
Yeah.
That's when I think of mark and that's what I think of Mikey and that's where I
think Orion
and that's when I think of,
when I think of
all those,
those brave souls,
those brave souls that a phone
and I always will
always will,
but you know,
it's not,
it's not a bad thing
and,
and I don't want you to think that it,
that it ruins the moment because it doesn't,
it doesn't at all.
It doesn't fill me with sadness or with sorrow or with pain.
Okay.
It doesn't make me angry or frustrated
or depressed or dark.
It doesn't make me focus on on death.
No,
it
doesn't do that at all.
Yeah.
It makes,
it makes me want to live.
Makes me want to live more and do more.
It makes me want to be more
10 to know at those moments,
those precious moments,
this,
this life,
this life is a gift from those men.
They gave this to me,
they gave me that moment
and because
they gave it to me,
they don't have it anymore.
They gave us everything they had,
everything they had,
they gave to us.
So I'm grateful,
grateful to them.
And when I think of them,
I'm not sad.
When I think of them,
I'm happy,
I'm happy I knew them.
I,
I'm,
I'm happy I served with such heroes
and I'm happy
that day gave me the chance to be happy
today
and I won't let
the dark specter of death drag me down.
Oh,
remember them
and,
and for them
I will live.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
So
Echo,
did you take a quick minute or 47 minutes and explain how someone can support
this if they want to?
Yup.
So
I'm going to go right into it.
If you're into supplements actually,
even if you're not into supplement on it.
Supplements.
It's actually not just supplements though.
It's like all kinds of stuff to improve your whole life game physical like so
yeah.
Supplements,
whatever.
So mental,
mental,
physical,
um,
emotional,
even new mood.
It's called noon.
Tried that.
I don't want a new mood.
Yeah.
Somebody told me I should smoke pot.
Sure.
Like,
Hey,
you should go,
you should just try it.
You know,
you're out of the military now.
You should just,
you know,
she'll try some pot.
And I was like,
oh,
interesting.
But like why,
why do you think you know I should do that?
And they said,
well,
you know,
you,
you won't be so angry all the time then.
And I said,
I like being angry.
I don't think I'll try your potion.
Yeah.
Which is also kind of strange.
Even that,
I mean I know you don't actually like being angry.
You are also not angry all the time.
That's true.
I don't think I've ever seen you angry,
but me be three times ever.
Where did I get angry?
You were angry at Dean for something.
Okay.
Well.
Yeah.
And then something else actually.
So one time though,
that was the only time I could actually,
it was at dean twice.
Dean can be frustrating.
Hey Man.
And if you're angry all the time,
there's this thing called new mood by taking it.
I took it once but
I didn't feel like I was in a new mood.
But from the people that other people that take it cause you don't like,
okay,
so someone is like anything else.
It's like you're,
you're probably going to take the ones that you feel like you need or you want
help with.
You know,
like if you're like,
okay I got to recover better from it cause I work out so much,
you're going to take some kind of recovery thing.
You know my joints or whatever,
you're going to take krill oil or something for your gentle water.
So new mood is one of those ones where I was like,
okay,
I'm sleeping fine.
I don't have necessarily like hangover situations or depression or,
or anything where I need some enhancement.
Not to say that I couldn't benefit.
I'm not saying that,
but I'm saying I'm not gravitating towards,
I hear good things,
man.
I hear good thing.
Let's see what else.
Probably in the back of your mind you're like,
you know,
I'm cruising right now but I could probably cruise harder.
Actually no,
I bought it from my wife because she,
you know how like she's the kind where she like if there's a task like well
let's do the task,
real task,
you know?
Oh you're someone that likes to get stuff done.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You can see what you didn't like making videos.
The scenario right now
I it for her so was she wouldn't be so productive.
I like going to go cause she,
she said that stresses from it.
Especially with the new bay.
I mean kind of new six,
seven months,
whatever.
But you know like when it's time to go sleep,
you know the kind where,
I don't know if you're like this,
but you know the kind where me,
if I'm like,
Hey,
I'm going to go take a nap from three to four when I go in at two 59 to go take
a nap.
In the advent of me doing that,
I go into two 59 at three Oh one I'm probably either sleeping or close to sleep,
you know,
not everyone's like that where there'll be like all this stuff was on my mind
because you're going to take a nap and I'm like PTF,
PTF,
PTFE.
TFB tiff canceling.
Yes,
exactly.
So this new moon,
I took a nap the other day though.
I took a like serious nap.
I was just tired.
Slack,
tired on the couch.
That's kind of how it's,
yeah,
no couch naps are sort of,
I don't like the couch snaps to bet.
They're pretty dope cause I think you got to go,
I'm going to nab,
boom,
going to feed up,
elevate,
set the alarm clock,
couch Napa.
Just like what happened.
It was weird.
In a way.
And
I guess I'm just speaking from experience,
I don't have any like technical reason,
but what else
seems like the couch nap,
you're in this mental state that is kind of like you have low expectations and
comfort,
you know,
so your body is like,
you know what,
you might not be the most comfortable but hey,
you're not moving.
So boom,
you just bossy.
But when I,
when you can go like in your room and you lay down and you're like,
wait,
the temperature is just a little bit not cool.
And then you're like,
okay,
let me adjust the temp.
Oh wait,
wait,
wait.
I hear something outside.
Let me close the door.
You know?
So it's almost like you can't sleep because the conditions aren't perfect when
you have that expectation of perfect conditions.
But on the couch you don't have that expectation.
You're just like,
it's like if you're not being outside on a blanket,
I'll just pull this pillow over my left arm and that'd be good to go.
So yes,
I mean there just has to do with naps.
But the new mood one that's for like if you have like stress,
don't talk about.
If we don't know then talk about another thing.
Yeah,
I think we do know.
I think the conversation went in that direction of its own momentum.
I think the next thing you know we're talking about naps.
I know,
I know.
So on it.
Yeah.
Okay.
On is the best supplements.
That's it.
Let's get that out of the way.
Like straight up factually.
Um,
brother also they have like,
you know,
more your bar proud the other day so I got some more,
your bars already had them,
whatever did a workout and I like to eat after work.
I've got to get a certain amount of protein in there and not necessarily,
oh I'm going for counting my macros,
nothing like that.
But if you only have like one small piece of half piece of chicken leftover from
that,
you kind of need more.
My opinion,
I needed more so I was like,
but I made cool like he was like this brown rice.
It was good,
but I only had like this half piece of chicken.
So I was like,
shoot,
I need more meat in there.
Look in their fridge like nothing.
So like I got a worry to worry wears and chopped them up and like put it in
there and like did in no microwave.
He's actually good.
So it was like a buffalo meat,
chicken,
rice,
um,
concoction concoction.
It was good though.
Even you're used to worry about,
it's kind of like beef jerky or like,
uh,
was it like soft and moist?
It was,
no,
he wasn't solid.
It was still the warrior bar.
It was just a warm warrior borrowed.
It worked.
The flavor profile or majestically Oh,
I have to give that one a anyway word.
Whereas if you didn't know what that is there,
look on on a.com and this buffalo meat in it still gluten free,
by the way.
Anyway.
So the main ones is what?
Krill oil for your joints.
You'd be surprised how much joint degeneration we all have.
That's what I think.
Okay.
Just get the Krill oil.
Also,
your genuine entice me into the longer conversations on that page.
I don't want to know about your joint degeneration.
No,
of course.
You're the one who turned me on to it.
So you can't degeneration joint.
I gave me for the oil for joint maintenance.
Okay.
This is why Krill.
So this Greg,
Greg train back entire asked me,
not yesterday,
not the last time I saw him Sunday.
I hear your fish oil.
Like what?
No,
he was one who asks it greatly.
Sister each.
Yeah.
He said Phil,
what's the difference between fish oil and Krill oil?
Cause I take fish oil or whatever.
What's the difference?
Okay,
here's the difference.
My,
uh,
my wife's dead would say that this dude for Krill is better.
This is why.
Because Krill oil,
the Omega threes,
Omega threes,
that's what you're going for.
So they both fish oil and Krill Omega threes.
So fish oil attaches to your triglycerides.
Krill oil,
Omega three attached here,
phospholipids.
So what does that mean?
Who Cares?
Right?
Well,
I just want it,
you know,
am I doing it?
So
let's say your joints are in nightclub.
Okay,
follow me.
This is perfect analogy.
Your joints,
joints,
or a nightclub.
That's your joints and you want the Omega threes to get in there,
right?
Right.
So e Omega threes,
are these your crew?
Jocko is triglycerides.
Echo is phospholipids.
Okay.
Hey Jocko is cool.
His crew,
they'll make it a three.
So we both have Omega threes with us.
They're attached to me were me and you are on the guest list.
Hey,
who am I going to let in?
Jocko and his rowdy crew of Omega threes,
AP seals.
They do burpees at random times.
They want,
you know,
or echo cause they're just cruising.
They both spend money.
They both all though make it three spend money.
They gotta be in the nightclub,
but we do Omega threes is the bouncing going to let in your Omega threes,
threes attached to you.
The triglyceride
or to the phospholipids.
Whose me?
Who probably me.
So anyway,
boom.
That's why the Krill oil gets led in better 14 minutes.
40 minutes.
I like two minutes.
But you see what I'm saying?
That's basically how your body is.
So it's like,
hey,
it's better absorption.
Krill oil in that,
you know,
Krill oil,
Krill oil format.
Okay.
For lack of better term.
It just gets better absorption.
There's other stuff too.
Some antioxidants stuff,
donations university here.
Anyway.
Get the Krill oil,
take care of your joints.
You'd be surprised the roles they play in everything.
That's my opinion.
If you're not on that,
get on that.
Also,
a good way to support Amazon,
click through what you do is you go be free.
Do Your Amazon shopping even don't already before you do your Amazon shopping,
go to the website Jocko,
podcast.com or chocolate store,
whichever.
Click on the Amazon link.
Also,
it's also called support.
Click on support where the Amazon link,
whatever.
Then you can sell,
you click through the website.
Then you go do your Amazon shopping.
Outstanding way to support
really good support.
Then you do shopping as you normally would in boom,
instant support and you know it doesn't cost you anything.
It costs you two seconds of your time for big support.
So it's like,
you know,
small action,
big reaction
like sodium and water.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
yeah,
so you understand now if you're,
if you know what happens to sodium metal when you put it in water,
that's going to be used.
That's the Amazon Click.
I'm just saying,
I think it's important to like remember that cause it's,
that's important.
That's dope.
That's dope time.
Subscribe to the podcast on Itunes,
stitcher,
Google,
play all of the
podcast platforms and write a review.
If you're in the mood,
that's a good one.
Write a review.
So part the rankings,
if our podcast is in good ranking,
that's cool,
right?
Yeah,
I guess so.
I think so.
Uh,
or subscribe to or an subscribe to Youtube.
If you're into youtube,
you watch videos,
you can see this podcast obviously in video format or all the excerpts that we
put on there.
You said that like there's this massive,
there is,
there is and there's more coming.
And you know these are good because you can share them with your friend.
You know,
if so,
okay.
So I have some technical knowledge of,
so I know how to share the link and then in the link that I share,
I can manipulate the little URL or whatever.
So when they click on the link,
it'll start at a certain moment in the video.
Right.
It's not hard to do it.
You just,
there's little setting.
But anyway,
I can do that.
So if I'm,
if I'm like,
Hey,
let me share Jockos take on this with,
with my friend Jill or whatever,
then he,
cause I think he could benefit or this is what he was asking me about,
hey,
here it is.
I can send them the whole podcast.
I just manipulated the thing to the little bookmark place where he can start.
But if you don't,
you don't want to do all of that.
You can just find the excerpt that I put on the youtube channel,
you know,
they're just more sharable so they don't have to listen to the whole podcast to
get the,
that's a civic lesson.
That's really cool.
You'd think that there would be a lot of those from your excitement about them?
Yeah,
it depends on what you mean by a lot,
but I think,
yeah,
there's some significant,
you know.
Okay,
we're putting more on there.
You'll be the judge of that over here on this end.
Also Jocko has a store.
If you didn't know,
it's called Jocko store.com if you,
um,
you know,
if,
if you like these shirts that we make and we put effort into the shirts,
they're not like the cheap,
make a Stencil,
spray paint,
cheap Hanes,
nothing.
Hanes is cheap but cheap shirt here.
Can you give away for it?
It's not that kind of,
they're good like quality
seems scene.
I say the spray paint thing cause I've made shirts like that before when I was a
kid.
Yeah.
So they're not that kind of,
they're good.
They got some,
you know,
some cool does that.
Hey if you like,
I'm so check out those.
Go there Jacqueline,
store.com if you want to support in that way,
get a shirt and represent in the wild
boom women's stuff,
whatever.
Shirts,
patches,
rash guards,
19% performance increase,
proven hundred 47% proven 19% improvement.
Who does as well.
It's getting warmer.
I understand,
but still it's cold.
Someplaces Michigan called the hoodies are probably good for this time of year
right now know because they are the heaviest of weight.
Next winter we're going to go Jocko style on the hoodies.
They're gonna be heavy weight.
This year we would echo style,
lightweight,
Kohai,
Kohai there's still hoodies but they're not as heavy duty.
They're like medium,
heavy,
medium.
I think technically there,
I think there are medium heavy light detecting.
Next year we're going to heavy,
heavy,
heavy.
Yeah.
Um,
or we could go light for the spring summer as well.
Oh,
let's not just do the whole fashion thing where I'm going to make one time for
now.
Anyway,
go there and tell us,
look at what you want.
Bring Line of moving.
Stop bringing collection.
Yeah.
But yes,
if something looks good to you,
support that way.
Represent also psychological warfare.
Now look,
support the podcasts.
I dig it and thank you
everyone who supported,
but psychological warfare.
That one is a support yourself situation.
Really.
If you're weak,
this is what it is.
Psychological warfare.
If you didn't already.
I know.
Explain every time,
but I'm gonna explain it again.
If you're feeling moments of weakness in regards to your workout or waking up
early or slipping on the,
on the whole diet program.
And I don't mean Diet like I'm just saying,
eating correctly and not incorrectly.
If you're about to slip on that you get enticed,
like my sister explained she did with her son,
brings home some brownies,
she couldn't help it eat the brownies.
Now she's paying for it on the treadmill according to her,
her words,
not mine.
At the moment of the introduction of the brownies or donuts as the case may be,
you put on one of these tracks,
it's called sugarcoated lies,
snack time,
shoes,
Gert coated lies.
Listen to Jocko.
He'll explain to you some stuff that will cause you to not slip on that plan.
And this goes for,
like I said,
waking up during the workout,
uh,
pushing yourself during the workout,
all this stuff,
getting your work to all this stuff.
So if you need a spot in those areas,
look into that.
It's called psychological warfare,
Jocko Willink.
It's on iTunes.
Good way to support yourself and by happenstance it supports the podcast as
well.
Double whammy
double gravitational thing.
Also,
while you're clicking through Amazon,
you can order Jocko white tea.
You can get on amazon.com do the click through,
try it,
be careful,
be careful what you use it,
but give it a try,
see what happens and I've got a couple more just reviews from amazon.com
since taking it with me to the gym over ice.
I not only get to enjoy the semisweet flavor of the tea,
but I have also noticed increases in strength on squats.
I've noticed a 15 to 20% increase in strength while using it and my dead lift
has gone from four 75 to eight oh five extra minutes.
And by the way it says same I suite.
There's no sweetener in the tea.
It just is what it is,
you know,
sugar in there.
That would be just hypocritical and I would have to close down my life.
Another one,
no big deal.
I'm not a tea drinker but needed a sound substitute to kick the Diet Soda Jocko
White Tea is what the reviews say.
I drink it iced and I love the taste.
Since Drinking Jocko White Tea,
Mike Total and free t levels have increased.
I don't have the labs to back up my claim,
but my voice is deeper,
my muscles are leaner,
energy increased and my wife's favorite result is increased stamina.
I feel 21 again,
enjoy the tea and support the podcast.
Tang again,
science,
these are from Amazon,
right?
These are peer reviewed,
reputable,
reputable and Jocko white tea.
You can get it and you could write a funny review like everybody else is doing a
little book coming out called way of the warrior kid.
By the way,
it's coming out soon.
It's coming out May 2nd it's going to sell out and once people read the initial
ones that sell out the people that got it,
they're going to order more.
It's going to be back ordered and you're not gonna be able to get one.
It's ordered now real easy.
Also,
discipline equals freedom field manual that's coming in October.
Same thing.
Order it so you can get a copy.
When it comes out the manual,
we'll show you how to get after it.
That's it.
It's the field manual.
You will know how to get after it.
You get the field manual,
there's money equals freedom.
You've heard that.
You probably think that.
You actually probably know that.
How do you execute it?
You get the field man,
you following instructions,
workouts,
thoughts,
food intake,
sleep habits.
Everything's in there.
No factor.
Extreme ownership.
Also
it's just word of mouth,
keeping it in the top.
One to 200 on Amazon.
That's insane.
Thank you all for spreading the word
and getting your people in the game.
Get them a copy you don't want.
Write a little note in the copy that you get for your team.
I'm a little advice what chapter you think is suited for them.
Get them on board up and down the chain of command.
By the way,
you don't want your whole team to be outperforming your leadership,
which is what will happen if you just get the book for them and you
Ashkelon Front leadership and management consulting,
keynote speeches.
Yup.
We do those long range leadership alignment programs.
So yes,
that is what we do.
So me,
Lafe JP,
Dave Burke,
combat leadership applied to business and life and check the website echelon
front.com or email info@echelonfront.com also the muster,
and again,
this is not a seminar about getting pumped up.
No,
it isn't a seminar about finding yourself.
It's not going to help you channel your internal ci towards the eternal bliss.
It's not going to do that.
This is not what the musters about.
The muster is about leadership,
pragmatic leadership skills for you to use in your business and your life.
You work with people,
you lead people or you aspire to lead people who's going to teach you how to do
that?
Where are you gonna learn that from?
Actual question.
Where do you learn that from?
Who's going to teach it to you?
That's the question.
The answer is the muster.
Learn to lead your people.
Learn to lead yourself.
May 4th and fifth New York City Marriott,
Grand Marquis.
Are we playing around?
No,
we are not.
The first minister was awesome.
Agree.
Why are we having a second muster?
Because the first semester was awesome.
That's why we're having a second muster.
So come to it
and until we see you at the muster,
because by the way,
I'm going to be,
their life's going to be there.
Jp is going to be there.
Dave Burke going to be there.
That's not enough for you and you need something to kind of close the deal.
Don't worry cause Echo Charles is going to be,
they're probably giving the four hour speech to the public
until the muster.
You can also find us more on the interwebs cruising and an echoes case cruising
hard.
We're on Twitter,
Instagram and Facebook.
Echo is at Echo,
Charles and I am at jockowillink.
And lastly,
thanks for listening and giving us feedback and inspiring us to do this.
Inspiring us to do better and to be better
knowing that we aren't alone on this mission.
No one that you all are with us in the game.
Standing Watch,
not backing down,
not settling for average,
not just going through the motions,
but living,
living life,
living life hard and fast and aggressively,
and taking every opportunity to step up,
step forward,
step on fear and step on failure
in step toward a better you
and step out
into the unknown
to get after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.